Aber man kann doch jetzt FK schon auf Caps Lock legen.
Ja, aber dann hab ich ja keinen Caps Lock mehr.
Ja, okay, aber Caps Lock.
Leute, wirklich.
Man muss mir grad Zeit geben.
99,5% der Fälle, wo ich Capslock drücke, tue ich das ungewollt. Also von mir aus könnte die ganze Taste da verschwinden.
Täglich, häufig, gezielt, gerne.
Ich glaube, ich finde es ganz cool.
Ich dachte, du wärst eine coole Sau. Die Taste ist voll frei, die ist schön los. Du bist überhaupt kein Altschuh-Hacker.
Das ist bei allem insofern total problematisch, als dass man halt unter solchen Bedingungen auch überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, wie großartig das Interesse ist.
Klar, also es ist ja ohne Frage, dass sozusagen die technischen Schwierigkeiten suboptimal sind, aber ich würde trotzdem dabei bleiben, dass es immer noch kein Grund ist, in Panik zu verfallen und schon kilometerlange Blogposts darüber zu schreiben, wie schlimm das alles ist. Nur zur Erinnerung, der ganze Kongress ist nach wie vor sehr viel von freiwilligen Betrieben und organisiert auch das Ticketsystem. Es ist kein Multi-10.000-Dollar-Euro-Projekt, wofür jetzt eine Firma zur Rechenschaft gezogen wird, sondern es sind alle Nerds, die das... Aber dann nehme ich zumindest den Teil zurück. Das ging halt, das wusste ich nicht.
Er ist neu. Wir haben ja dasselbe für Lockbruch-Netzpolitik benutzt. Das ist an sich ein ziemlich cooles System. Das ist halt noch nicht hadend.
Aber das ist tatsächlich, zum Beispiel bei der Juroko, die ist ja auch so eine lange Zeit lang von diesen kleineren Konferenzen immer der Event war, wo alle unbedingt hinwollten. Und wir haben da auch bei jedem Jahr eine andere Stadt veranstaltet. Und jedes Jahr haben die Leute auch ein anderes Ticketsystem ausprobiert. Und jedes Jahr aufs neue war dann so hier das neue Ticket. Du kannst deine Tickets einfach hier bei uns verkaufen. Bam, glatt.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, das kann ich an dieser Stelle auch glatt einfach nochmal dazu sagen. Also das ist ja so ein generelles Problem, wenn man so ein Event hat. Und man will halt Leute daran teilnehmen lassen, dieses ganze Ticketing, Abrechnen und so weiter. Das ist halt voll nervig. Und du kannst dir das halt so von Xing oder diesem Eventbrite halt abnehmen lassen. Aber die haben halt auch ganz ordentlich Tanzien. Und das System hier, Pre-Ticks, das kommt halt so aus dem Umfeld, sag ich mal.
Also doch, immerhin mit Nerd, aber kommerzielle Nerds.
Ja genau, also Nerd-Lieders sozusagen jetzt als Business auch ersetzen. Also jetzt nicht nur ein Hack, der so für den Kongress läuft, sondern da ist halt was drin. Und das hat auch wirklich eine ganze Menge netter Features. Und das hab ich eigentlich mit Freude benutzt. Allein schon deshalb, weil es natürlich auch ein System ist, wo ich so direkt zu Griff auf die Leute hab. Und man kann mal so richtig anrufen und sagen, wie wär's, wenn man das so und so und so machen würde? Und nicht ganz mit einem ganzen Social-Media-Wirrwarr von Xing und so weiter überflutet wird. Mit einer Million Optionen, die man irgendwie eh nicht braucht. Und die richtig coolen Sachen sind halt nicht drin.
Und jetzt haben Sie sich für die nächste Runde ein paar Server oder Cloud-Instanzen noch mehr dazu geklickt, oder was?
Na ja...
Es ist ja sicher nicht in der Klare Tell.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, wie es sein wird, weil ich das jetzt nicht so täglich verfolge. Aber ich hab auch mal meinen Sermon reingegeben, wie ich meine, wie man das vielleicht machen sollte. Und dann kam im Wesentlichen dieses Jahr, das ist genau das, worüber wir gerade schon so nachgedacht haben. Die Kernidee ist, dass man quasi das Frontend so macht, dass man erst mal so eine Auflaufseite hat, wo du dann erst mal eine Warteschlange reinkommst. Und dann kriegst du halt einfach so einen Token, und das schlummert in so einem JavaScript. Und das wird dann einfach von der Webseite quasi aufgerufen. Also so Wartezimmerlogik. Das hat einfach den Vorteil, dass du mit Reload verlierest du dann quasi deine Warteliste. Das heißt, das kannst du halt auch nicht groß brute-force, weil du eben nicht auf das eigentliche Backend durchkommst, wenn du nicht das Token hast, was du halt vorher so bekommen hast.
Ich meine, das was... Ich hatte ja vor ein paar Wochen mal wieder so einen Talk bei der Rugby, hier der Ruby User Group gehalten, wo ich ja mal eine Lessons Learned aus 10 Jahren Programmieren so, Backends hacken, einen vorgetragen hab. Und ein Punkt davon war ja auch Benchmarken, Profilen und Load testen, weil das auch so irgendwie, das ist immer wieder das Thema. Huch, jetzt klicken da halt mal so zehntausende Leute drauf und alles geht in Arsch. Hätte man wahrscheinlich auch vorher wissen können. Aber es ist gar kein so direkter Vorwurf jetzt, weil das passiert einfach immer wieder und immer wieder und immer wieder.
Ja, also so wie ich es gehört hab, war halt so, wir wussten schon, dass da eine Menge kommt, aber wir konnten ja nicht ahnen, dass es so viel ist.
Ja, aber der Punkt von Load-Testing ist ja, dass man mal erstmal so guckt auch, wo sind die Grenzen? Also ich meine, das ist, also ich weiß ja nicht mit welchen Größenordnung sie gerechnet haben, aber das muss ja dann ein bis zwei Größenordnungen mehr gewesen sein, als sie vermutet hatten oder so. Naja, nächstes Mal ein bisschen Load testen. Könnte euch vielleicht helfen?
Genau, also pretix.eu kann ich empfehlen, ist cool. Macht halt noch nicht das ganze Geldmanagement für einen, das heißt, man muss das immer noch über eigenes Konto laufen lassen, aber kann halt so PayPal, kann Sepa und dann musst du irgendwie immer so deine Buchungen da per CSV reingießen. Aber dann hast du halt auch alles unter Kontrolle und du hast halt vor allem die Kohle schon vorher, was halt auch ein Feature ist. Weil so bei Xing oder so, wenn du da halt so ein Event machst, dann kriegst du das halt eine Woche nach Ablauf des Events überwiesen und damit fehlt dir halt unter Umständen einfach die komplette Kohle, um diesen Event vorzufinanzieren.
Genau, das hatten wir damals mit der Yurucu. Das ist ja schon eine Weile her. Da gab es auch noch nicht so viele von diesen Ticket-Seller-Seiten. Dann war das, was wir benutzt hatten, halt sozusagen direktes Durchleiten zu PayPal. Und PayPal hat dann irgendwann gesagt, oh, ungewöhnliche Kontoaktivität, wir sperren jetzt erst mal das Konto. Bis jetzt also geklärt ist, ob dieses Geld, was da in Strömen einfließt, auch alles rechtmäßig ist. Und dann saßen wir halt auch so da mit so, weiß ich nicht, wie viele tausend Euro auf diesen PayPal-Konto, wo wir nicht rankamen. Was wir aber auch natürlich wiederum zur Vorbereitung der Konferenz eigentlich sehr gerne gehabt hätten.
Was auch noch ganz geil ist, bei PreTix, ich hör mir jetzt gerade erst wieder alles ein, das haben wir auch benutzt, es gibt für Android eine App. Also einfach unseren Android-Phone nehmen, installierst du den PreTix-Droid und dann kriegst du einfach auf der Webseite, um das Ding zu aktivieren, kriegst du so ein QR-Code auf dem Bildschirm, hältst du das Telefon davor und dann provisioniert sich das Teil komplett über diesen QR-Code. Also es ist halt eine URL drin, verbindet sich und schlupst sich quasi so alle Eventdaten rein und dann ist das Ding fertig. Dann kannst du dich an eine Kasse stellen und jeden ausgedruckten QR-Code oder QR-Code auf dem Device, also die Tickets quasi einfach einscannen und fertig. So, und das war echt ziemlich pragmatisch, weil der gesamte Hardware-Aufwand für Kasse ist sozusagen ein so ein dozeliges Telefon mit Kamera und dann hast du dann quasi deinen Ticket-Checker.
Na ja, wollen wir mal schauen, wie das funktioniert dann.
Genau.
So muss sein.
Also, so sollte es sein.
Die letzten Jahre hatten wir ja auch immer die Wallet vom iPhone unterstützt. Ist das dieses Jahr auch so?
Achso, du meinst, dass so ein Passcode-Ding kommt? Ja, das ist jetzt auch drin.
Besser ist.
Das kam so auf den letzten Metern. Das Feature wurde dann sozusagen für den Kongress gerade gehackt und so.
Gerade noch fertig.
Gerade noch fertig. Aber da sind wirklich einige wirklich sehr nette Sachen drin, diese ganze Quotaregelung und so weiter. Da kann man sehr flexibel mit arbeiten. Ja, und das macht auch so den Eindruck, als ob es schnell noch viel besser wird.
Ich habe ja auch jetzt in meiner Freizeit vor, so latenten Event zu organisieren. Allerdings richtet der sich eher an die Musikfreunde unter unseren Hörern. Und da es ja durchaus auch ein paar Musikfreunde hier gibt. Und in meinem kleinen Gitarrenpodcast, da gibt es zwar auch einige Hörer, aber ich würde mal sagen, hier über die Freak Show gibt es vielleicht doch noch die Chance, ein paar mehr zu erreichen. Und zwar gibt es so meinen Lieblingsgitarist quasi und Konnisseur namens Greg Koch, oder Coq, wie es in Englisch ausgesprochen wird. Der kommt, also wer den nicht kennt, ist eigentlich schon mal schwierig, aber wie soll ich das kurz zusammenfassen? Auf jeden Fall ist er ein supergenialer Gitarist, sehr artikuliert, macht vor allen Dingen so Blues-Geschichten, aber kann eigentlich alles spielen, macht halt auch so ganz viele Workshops und so weiter, macht sehr viele YouTube-Videos, ist megawitzig. Und der kommt so auf Tour, alle paar Jahre lang nach Deutschland, weil irgendwie aus irgendeinem Grund, der in Deutschland besonders eigentlich bekannt ist, aber er war noch nie in Berlin, noch nie, oder vielleicht ganz lange her. Er spielt dann irgendwo in Hintertupfingen in irgendeiner Blues Bar, der ist mal bei Thomann in der großen Veranstaltungsbühne, auch mal in Hamburg oder so, aber in Berlin ist er nie. Jetzt überlege ich halt mal, so ein Event zu organisieren, wo der sozusagen herkommt, Konzert spielt, vielleicht auch einen Workshop macht, und würde halt eigentlich nur mal wissen wollen, wie viele Leute da Interesse dran haben, um sozusagen schon vorher zu wissen, ob das sich überhaupt lohnt, oder dass es einen ganz klaren Grund gibt, warum der nie in Berlin spielt, weil es einfach keine Sau hier interessiert. Falls ihr also...
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dazu ist die Stadt zu groß.
Das kann ich mir eigentlich auch nicht vorstellen. Also es bräuchte auch nur so 100 Leute, dann würde sich das alles schon lohnen, den ganzen Aufwand zu fahren. Der braucht halt mit seinem Gitarren, mit seinem Blues Trio auch so ein bisschen Kohle halt, für Unterkunft zumindest, und die Location muss bezahlt werden. Falls ihr Interesse habt, pinkt mich vielleicht auch mal so lose auf Twitter an oder schickt mir ein Gitarren-Emoji auf Twitter, dann weiß ich Bescheid. Und wenn ihr nicht Greg Koch kennt, dann packe ich mal einen Link in die Show-Notes. Kickstarter. Ja, erstmal will ich so ganz lose wissen, ob es überhaupt irgendeine signifikante Menge Interesse gibt. Es gibt eine YouTube-Playlist von mir mit so seinen von mir favorisierten Videos, die solltet ihr von unten anfangen zu konsumieren.
Von unten eine Playlist?
Ja, die letzte Hinzuverfügung. Wenn ihr auf die Playlist klickt, das erste Video ist halt das älteste, was ich hinzugefügt habe. Ich würde die von unten anfangen. Ich pack das mal in die Show Notes. Genau, Greg Koch, da ist schon ein Foto im Chat. Der sieht halt auch, ich glaube, warum er, er ist einer der besten Gitarrenspieler, die es auf der Welt gibt, definitiv. Und ich glaube, der Grund, warum er nicht zu Welt rumgelangt ist, ist, dass er aussieht wie ein Autoverkäufer oder Versicherungsvertreter. Und nicht wie ein cooler Rockstar, aber der kann wirklich krass gut spielen und ist eben auch sehr witzig und nimmt sich auch selber nicht so ernst. Er ist wirklich mein Gitarrenvorbild in der Hinsicht. Naja, auf jeden Fall, den würde ich gerne mal nach Berlin holen.
Lohnt sich das hier mal was anzustellen?
Ja, in meiner Playlist sind eigentlich die coolsten Videos. Aber jetzt auch nicht für die Sendung.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was hinter diesen Videos hier steht.
Ja, die... warte, ich such dir was raus. Also, der macht halt zum Beispiel auf YouTube, macht ja für so einen Gitarrenladen halt immer so Demos von Gitarren und erzählt halt irgendeinen Quatsch dazu. Und eins meiner Lieblingsvideos ist eigentlich das hier. Das packe ich mal in die Schaunen. Aber es ist nicht jetzt für den Podcast wirklich toll zum Abspielen. Das ist wirklich, ja, das ist halt das Format, wirst du doch nicht mal in Ruhe angucken.
Ich spiele jetzt irgendwas ab. Weil man überhaupt eine Ahnung hat, um was das geht.
Naja, das sind jetzt...
Außer Gitarre.
Ja. Habe ich das nicht? Also das ist jetzt halt so ein Video, wo du halt siehst, dass er Gitarre spielen kann. Das fängt halt jetzt leider so ein bisschen öder an, weil er nur mal kurz ein paar Sachen anspielt, aber gleich geht's los. Ich gebe ihm 10 Sekunden.
Wer ist der beste Gitarre-Spieler der Welt?
Naja, das ist halt Quatsch, natürlich so eine Liste anzuführen.
Aber...
Von welchen Kriterien?
Genau. Aber der ist halt... Der ist einfach... Der kann alles spielen. Also du kannst sagen, Spiel Jimi Hendrix, Spiel Stevie Ray Vaughan, Spiel Jimi Page, Spiel irgendwas, Spiel Jazz. Und er spielt das halt einfach perfekt. Und vor allen Dingen kann er halt auch so dir genau aufschlüssen, so diese Licks oder diese Riffs, die Jimi Hendrix gespielt hat, die hat er halt von dem sich abgeguckt. Der hat das so gespielt, Jimi Hendrix hat das rausgemacht und er zeigt dir einfach so alles so, die Matrix. Wie gesagt, guckt euch mal meine Playlist an. Da sind auch so ein paar Videos, wo er Workshops macht und auch erzählt, wie er so ans Gitarrespielen rangeht und so weiter, und die sind schon sehr aufschlussreich. Die Demo-Videos sind halt cool, weil die sind teilweise in 4K-Auflösungen aufgenommen und du kannst ja echt viel von ihm abgucken. Und 4K ist wirklich für so Gitarren-Lernkram mega geil, weil du siehst wirklich ganz genau, wo die Finger sind und so. Ja, absolut. Und jetzt fängt er gleich so abzugehen. Also er hat manchmal Tage, wo er viel Kaffee getrunken hat. Das ist ein Gag.
Gag?
Das ist auch noch lustig.
Der geht halt richtig ab teilweise in diesen Videos und ich würde den halt echt gerne auch live sehen, weil der hat mit seinem Blues-Trio spielt auch einfach richtig geilen Sound. Ist für alle was dabei. Also schreibt mir einen Gitarren-Emoji auf Twitter, damit ich mal so ein bisschen Interesse erkennen kann. Wie viele Gitarren-Emojis? Ja wahrscheinlich gibt's mittlerweile einige. Achso ich hab ja ein altes Mac OS, ihr habt ja mehr.
Du meinst ich soll jetzt mal hier gucken?
Geil, da fühl ich mich nicht so alleine.
Ihr habt beide noch keinen Sierra?
Ich hab Sierra nur auf diesem iMac und hatte halt auch merkwürdige Effekte.
Also ich hab nur eine Gitarre.
Ich hab auch nur eine Gitarre. Aber dafür hab ich den Facepalm schon, weil ich die Beta, die hat er einfach installieren wollen.
Und deine Gitarre sieht auch noch anders aus. Das ist ein Stratocaster. Ich hab hier, guck mal, was ist denn das für eine Gitarre?
Das ist eine Gibson oder so ähnlich. Aber stimmt, ich hab ne amtliche Strat.
Weil du so davon sprachst, wenn er so erzählt, wie du die Gitarre spielst und so weiter, hast du auf Arte mal dieses Three Legends Rock gesehen?
Das war nicht schlecht, aber ich fand es auch ein bisschen...
Es hat dir nicht gefallen.
Ein paar fremde Momente waren schon dabei. Jimmy Page war schon der Coolste von den dreien, fand ich. Weil der alte Rock-Opa, dem alles gar nicht mehr so interessiert, wer jetzt der Coolste ist und so. Und gegen Jack White da schon immer so ein bisschen so auf...
Was ist der angesagt? Also kann der Gitarre spielen? Hat der irgendwas zu melden?
Der kann schon was natürlich.
Der kann schon Gitarre spielen, ja.
Ja, aber davon denen gibt es noch Tausende.
Ja, hast schon recht, aber...
Also der ist jetzt noch nicht im Rock-Roll-Of-Fame-Himmel oder wie auch immer das da heißt.
Jaaa...
Da gehört er auch noch nicht hin, oder?
Ja... Also ja, nee, würde ich schon so zustimmen, ja. Und die Edge so gesehen...
Würde ich da aber auch nicht hintun.
Würde ich da auch nicht unbedingt hintun. Also Jimmy Page war halt einfach so von den dreien die Legende TM. Und die anderen beiden waren halt so ganz nettes Beilwerk, aber hätte man eigentlich auch nur für Jimmy Page machen können.
Bei The Edge habe ich immer so das Gefühl, der kann verdammt gut Effektgeräte spielen. Also der hat so viel Zeug am Start, der braucht die Gitarre selber eigentlich kaum noch.
Nur für den initialen Ton halt, ja. Also der Rolling Stone hier im Magazin, der hat so eine Liste natürlich gemacht, die 100 besten Gitarristen der Welt, weil du gefragt hast, wer ist denn jetzt der beste Gitarrist und so. Und natürlich sind so eine Liste immer sehr fragwürdig, weil nach welchen Kriterien ist schon ganz richtig. Und die haben das natürlich so ein bisschen aufgezogen, wer hat jetzt sozusagen am meisten geprägt mit seinen stilistischen Eigenentwicklungen. Und da finde ich die Liste schon tatsächlich, also natürlich mit hier plus minus ein paar Prozent, schon ziemlich gut. Und Jimi Hendrix ist glaube ich schon auch ganz vorne mit dabei. Also wenn nicht auf Platz eins, dann auf jeden Fall Top Ten, 100%ig.
Also ich bin ja überhaupt nicht so ein Gitarrentyp, aber ich habe signifikante Zeiten meines Lebens in das Zuhören von Mark Knopfler.
Der ist auch ganz vorne mit dabei, ja.
Sultans of Swing sag ich.
Der hat aber auch andere coole Songs gemacht. Allerdings der eine, den alle kennen.
Das war das Debütalbum und damit sind sie halt so irgendwie auf der Bildfläche erschienen und alle so, was geht denn da ab? Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Mein Hero früher war ja hier Richie Blackmore von Deep Purple. Und in letzter Zeit ist es aber eher hier Johnny Greenwood von Radiohead.
Ja, die sind auch alle in der Liste vorhanden. Ja, also die kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal angucken, die Liste, da findet man schon gar nicht so falsche Einordnungen.
Hast du da einen Link zu?
Das ist ein ziemlicher Krampf, die durchzuscrollen. Ich hab die nämlich gerade angeschaut für die Drummer aus Interesse und die fangen halt wirklich bei 100 an. Du hast eine Beschreibung, du hast ein Foto. Dann kannst du erstmal schön nach unten scrollen.
Ja, ja, es dauert alles eine ganze Weile, da durchzuklicken.
Ach, du musst immer für jeden ein, zwei einfach klicken?
Na klar, natürlich, sonst kannst du doch deine geblockte Werbung gar nicht einblenden. Ach so, nee, Moment, das ist aber gar nicht die Liste.
Da steht Rolling Stone.
Vielleicht haben sie die umformatiert. Okay, dann kannst du jetzt doch scrollen vielleicht. Na ja, anyway, ist ja auch nicht so wichtig. Der Greg Koch ist auf jeden Fall ganz vorne mit dabei. In meiner Liste, der ist nicht da drin, weil er halt einfach nicht so ein Weltalbum produziert hat, aber er rockt trotzdem. Ich klick mal da oben, da ist so ein Taps, da kannst du gleich auf 1 bis 20 klicken. Na, du bist zu weit unten.
Geklagt kann er, auch wenn man die Songs nicht mag, aber er kann spielen, oder?
Er hat auf jeden Fall auf 4 geprägt, gerade so in jungen Zeiten.
Vor allem bei ihm merkt man halt, dass viele Songs sich eigentlich nur auf die Gitarre konzentrieren. Also man kann bei ihm die Gitarre immer gut klar raushören.
Ja, und Jimmy Page auf 3 auf jeden Fall korrekt, yeah.
Machen wir noch ein bisschen weiter? Lass mal die ersten 10 durchgucken.
Hab ich auch viel Zeit mit verbracht.
Der geht eher unter mit seiner Gitarre, oder?
Na ja, also für die Begründung sozusagen, die sie da reinschreiben, ist es halt wie gesagt so ein bisschen so der... nicht nur die Technik sozusagen, sondern eben auch so Sound, Attitüde, Prägung, Inspiration. Und der hat schon auch natürlich den Sound da von einer nicht allzu kleinen und nicht allzu unbekannten Band sehr gepflegt.
Diese fucking Rolling Stones, die rollen.
Aber Bob Dylan spielt auch noch immer, und der ist auf der Neverending Tour. Aber der hört ja nicht auf zu touren. Die Rolling Stones, die kommen ja nur alle paar Nasen lang mal wieder in die Gänge.
Was hat er jetzt eigentlich gemacht?
Abgesagt, er hat gesagt, er kann nicht als verhindert.
Er hat sich geäußert?
Heute oder gestern.
Aber er hat nicht gesagt, dass er ihn nicht nimmt?
Nein, da hat er sich ja schon vor, zu geäußert.
Er schickt jemand anderen.
Er meinte, er war erstmal sprachlos und konnte dazu jetzt erstmal nichts sagen. Er hat sich erst mal zwei Wochen Gedanken gemacht, wie er darauf reagiert.
Klingt ja auch schon ein bisschen wie der Ausrede.
Der hat ja sein ganzes Leben. Wenn man sich mal seine Dokus und Biografien durchlegt, der hat ja schon immer ein Problem damit, wenn man ihn zu einem Idol oder Symbol machen will. Von außen, weil er darauf irgendwie keinen Bock hat. Und ich glaube, gerade Nobelpreis ist eigentlich die ultimative Strafe für ihn.
Als ob das jetzt noch viel ändern würde.
Das ist der von Pink Floyd hier, der Clemore. Die paar richtig coolen Songs, die sind auch von ihm und nicht von dem Roger Waters. Also zum Beispiel Echoes, glaube ich. So gesehen, ja.
Ja, hat auf jeden Fall auch einen starken Einfluss hinterlassen. Oder ist ja auch immer noch dabei, aber influenziert nicht mehr so viel.
Der alte Sack.
Das sind auf jeden Fall einige Namen dabei, die ich überhaupt null kenne.
Ja, der davor gerade, wie auch immer der hieß.
Wer war das davor? Den kenne ich auch nicht tatsächlich. Almond Brothers, na gut. Ach nee, Raze sind die Almond Brothers. Nee, sagt mir auch nicht der Typ.
Müssen wir jetzt auch nicht alle durchgehen. Wir haben irgendwie einen Pen-Hammer schon durch. Genau, haben wir mal über Gitarren geredet. Letty, magst du Gitarrenmusik?
Ich habe sogar mal versucht Gitarre zu spielen, aber wir sind nie Freunde geworden.
Du musst mal dein Mikro vor deine Schnute...
Ja, ich will ja nicht Vadern, das ist...
Darfst du auch nicht Vadern, das ist Copyrighted.
Wenn die beiden Vadern, kannst du die Phase umdrehen und dann löscht sich das gegenseitig aus.
Ins Recording schafft das Vadern es ja eh nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr verpasst.
Richtig gemacht. Advanced Vadering.
Professionelles Vadern.
Das Vadern ist ja demnächst wieder im Kino, ne?
Vadern vor Dummies, also 300 Seitenbuch draus machen.
Vadern für kleine Sturmtruppen.
Letty, schnell Situation retten.
Ein Hornkostüm. Keine Ahnung. Von meinen nicht vorhandenen Gitarrenfreunden.
Freuden.
Ach, Freuden. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie Nachbarn so toll fanden und dass Freuden waren für andere. Ich weiß nicht. Ja, ich mag die Musik schon. Ich bin aber, ich stell grad fest, dass ich glaube ich, Stimmen, also die Stimme als Instrument, viel spannender finde bei einigen Menschen. Als ein Instrument.
Mal so, mal so halt, ne? Genau, Monokulturen sind immer scheiße.
Genau. Lass uns lieber über Apple reden.
Zum Thema Monokulture, war das jetzt die perfekte Überleitung?
Die haben doch bestimmt auch eine passende Stecker für die Gitarre.
Nee, das haben sie nicht. Meinst du einen Adapter?
Ja, genau, danke.
Einen 6,3mm Thunderbolt Adapter habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
So, jetzt haben wir uns ja hier letztes Mal ausführlich zu Macbook Pro geäußert. Ich muss sagen, ich habe die Sendung alles ganz gut in Erinnerung. Hast du gehört, Hucke?
Nee, ich wäre gerne dabei gewesen, habe aus Gram, weil ich nicht dabei bin, auch gar nicht erst reingehalten.
Muss man sowas anhören, dann hätte man jetzt schön anschließen können. Jetzt weißt du gar nicht, was für coole Unsinn ist. Ich fand es gut.
So viel Unsinn war das ja gar nicht. Ich habe euch zugehört.
Na bitte, dann fassen wir mal zusammen.
Von oben, ne?
Macht doch mal eine Zeichnung. Wer hat wann was gesagt? Ja, von oben.
Ich meine, du hast ja ja so ein Ding bestellt, also haben wir dich nicht davon abgebracht.
Das hört mein Arbeitgeber bestimmt jetzt total gern. Warum solltet ihr mich davon abbringen, so einen Schrottbuck zu bestellen, wenn ich dafür nicht zahlen muss? Also ich meine, das ist ja dann schon der Punkt.
Darum geht es ja auch ein bisschen um die Ehre, ne?
Also ich sitze das aus.
Also ich würde es mir persönlich auch nicht unbedingt kaufen. Nee, aber da geht es ja eher so ein bisschen drum, da kann man mal was ausprobieren, was man vielleicht nicht so schön findet.
So ähnlich mache ich das mit meinem Arbeitgeber auch.
Huch, alle machen das so.
Also du läufst jetzt gerade mit einem 15 Zoll MacBook Pro rum.
Du hättest schon wieder ein neues. Ach nee, ich hätte ein privates.
Ich hätte ein privates, genau. Wechsel jetzt oder kaufe mir dazu, lass mir dazu kaufen, einen 13 Zoll MacBook Pro mit TouchBar. Ich meine, meine größte Sorge war, dass sie da die Klinke weg reduzieren. Und ich hab den Stecker auch in der Tat am Anfang nicht gesehen und dachte mir so, oh mein Gott. Ja, das war so wirklich so mein scheißloses Ding hin. Aber ich wurde darauf hingewiesen, dass es dann doch da ist. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß noch nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, weil ich brauche jetzt für alles einen Adapter und ich werde immer den falschen Adapter dabei haben.
Oder das Kabel hat immer beim falschen Adapter einen Wackel, Dingsbumms, Schnuffi, Schnuff. In der Uni, wo ich hier immer so meinen Kurs noch mache, da ist ja immer noch das Ding hier, die haben ja jetzt HDMI-Kabel, da brauche ich halt auch einen Adapter. Und auch im Jahre 2016 kommt es dann vor, mitten im Semester ist dann dieses Kabel kaputt. Keiner kümmert sich das jetzt zeitnah auszutauschen, sitze da, rum mit rum. Ich meine, bei Beeman und diesen Fernsehkabeln, das eh hoffnungslos bereits 1.000 verschiedene Kabel gibt. Aber wenn das jetzt für alle sozusagen der Fall ist.
Ja, aber...
Also was ich halt wirklich sehr spannend finde, ist diese TouchBar einfach, um damit rumzuspielen und die mal zu benutzen.
Warte mal, ganz kurze Anmerkung. Das hatten wir glaube ich in der letzten Sitzung auch irgendwie rausgearbeitet, aber es gibt ja jetzt mit dem ganzen Thunderbolt und Usb-C Quatsch halt ja eine ganz andere Generation von Adaptern. Also ich glaube viele denken halt immer nur so von eins auf ein anderes. Klar, das hat man vielleicht auch, aber es gibt ja jetzt sozusagen auch diese Kombi-Dinger, so quasi so Mini-Docs.
Und was kosten die?
Die gar nicht so teuer sind.
Was heißt denn gar nicht so teuer?
Na, das hatte ich doch hier erzählt, hier so ein Teil, wo Ethernet, HDMI, nochmal Usb-C und nochmal ein Usb-A rauskommen für 60 Euro oder sowas.
Ja, aber irgendwo habe ich so ein Ding gesehen, wo jemand so ein, irgendwie, was meinte er, das teuerste Dock von Amazon...
Ja, der hat halt gezwungen, irgendwie drei Adapter hintereinander zu schalten, also von Thunderbolt 3 auf 2, wahrscheinlich auf USB.
Moment, nein, nein, nein, der hatte einen Adapter, den irgendwie, meinte, den günstigsten, den teuersten, den es bei Amazon gab. Und dann hat er diesen Adapter angeschlossen und ging irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Dann hat das Ding die externe Festplatte nicht mehr erkannt und das Video hat geflackert und das war alles irgendwie, na ja. Nee, aber ich hab noch mal drüber nachgedacht. Was mich ehrlich gesagt am meisten dran stört, ist, dass von allen Anschlüssen, die man bisher hatte, allen, also jetzt mal abgesehen von Kopfhörern, sind halt alle weg und durch einen Anschluss ersetzt, den bisher noch keiner hatte. Und das ist halt irgendwie schon ein harter Schock. Also da kann man jetzt über jeden einzelnen Anschluss von vorher reden und wegdiskutieren, warum man den nicht mehr braucht und warum Usb-C jetzt besser ist. Aber es sind halt alle weg. Und nur noch Usb-C, was keiner hat.
Na ja, die sitzen da und denken sich, wir könnten jetzt hier Usb-2 Stück machen und dann machen wir noch zwei alte Usb-Dinger dran, damit die Leute nicht so rumholen. Was passiert? Der Markt, der sich auf neue Usb-C-Geräte umschwenken würde, tut es nicht mehr, weil ist ja noch das normale Usb dran. Das heißt, wir müssen uns ja gerade anstrengen.
Da sind wir ja schon bei dem Punkt, dass wir uns nicht mehr anstrengen.
Ich verstehe die Argumentation, die dahinter ist. Total. Nur, das war so das, was ich letztes Mal irgendwie nicht mehr ausgedrückt bekommen hab, war so dieses es ist jetzt einfach alles weg.
Ist wie mit der seriellen, dauert ein, zwei Jahre, tut ein bisschen weh, Übergangsphase und dann ist Ruhe im Karton.
Okay, wir werden das in zwei Jahren mal gegen die Realität dann vergleichen.
Und dann Ruhe im Karton.
Ich hab dir mal gerade so einen Adopter hier aufgerufen. Der kostet irgendwie auf Amazonien 45 Euro.
Du hast ja schon mal so Kram von Amazon, die nicht von Apple sind, für 45 Euro bestellt.
Ich kenne Leute, die das benutzen und zufrieden sind. Ich weiß, da gibt es auch Sonne und Sonne, aber die Auswahl ist halt auch relativ groß. Und ich denke, das ist halt auch der Trend. Früher war es halt nur Adapter. Mini Displayport auf Displayport, und dieses bisschen auf jenes bisschen, und USB auf Internet und so ein Kram. Und jetzt kannst du halt, Usb-C ist ja was anderes. Und ich finde das ganz geil, weil wenn du jetzt, Letty, sagst, ich brauche jetzt für allen möglichen Scheiß einen Adapter, ich glaube, das läuft eher darauf hinaus, dass du für 99% von allem, was dir normalerweise über den Weg läuft, genau einen einzigen Adapter brauchst, den du auch einfach mal mit dabei hast, genauso wie du deinen Netzteil dabei hast. Und da könntest du trotzdem noch eins anschließen.
Aber ich meine, wenn es Bedarf für diesen Adapter gibt, dann gibt es auch Nachfrage für diese Ports. Und das Problem ist jetzt wirklich, wenn du diesen Adapter nimmst und hier so neben deinen Notebook hängst, dann ist das Problem wirklich genau eine Stufe weiter. Und du hast von diesem tollen Usb-C-Port überhaupt nichts gewonnen, außer dass dein Notebook halt dünner ist.
Na doch, du hast halt alle möglichen nativen Anschlüsse, die du sonst so nie hattest.
Und es gibt einen Adapter, den gibt es gar nicht. Das ist von den alten Netzteilen, von denen ich einige noch habe, auf Usb-C zum Laden. Gibt es halt nicht. Du kriegst halt einen Netzteil dazu. Und wenn du aber mehr als ein Netzteil brauchst, dann kannst du halt Stromadapter kaufen.
Und übrigens gibt es das dicke schwere Kabel mit der Basse oder Erdung oder wie auch immer, gibt es nicht dabei. Kostet 19 Dollar. Hat Timmerletts erzählt, dass er das Video gesehen hat?
Schoko, das Schokokabel.
Das ist doch dabei oder wie?
Nee, das ist nicht dabei.
Das ist nicht dabei.
Da ist nicht schwarz, das ist weiß. Wir reden hier von diesem dicken Schokokabel hier. So, jetzt aber TouchBar.
Findest du, dass das selten benutzt wird? Ich benutze das zuhause immer.
Ich benutze das nur. Das ist da dran und fertig.
Ich benutze das nie unterwegs, aber im Studio benutze ich es nur, weil Studio, Audio, Brumm.
Ja gut. Stimmt, zuhause habe ich es auch dran.
Weißt du noch, als ich das nicht hier hatte, dann hatten wir hier immer so schön Brumm, wenn man seinen Laptop anpasst. Genau, Brumm und Britzel. Und seitdem ich hier korrekte Verkabelungen habe, gibt es das nicht mehr.
Ich habe da eher einen pragmatischen Ansatz, dass das Kabel reicht vom Schreibtisch bis zum Bett.
Oder schlägst im Büro?
Manchmal arbeite ich auch vom Klo.
Reicht da das Kabel auch hin?
Etwas mehr Details, als mir es lieb gewesen wäre. Du wolltest was zum TouchBar sagen.
Genau, Übergang. Das finde ich in der Tat mal spannend. Die zu benutzen, also ich meine jetzt gerade für Visualisierungen einfach mal rumzuspielen, damit ob ich die halt wirklich so ohne weiteres auch selber ansteuern kann, was ich damit machen kann. Ich glaube, das sehen gerade viele in meiner Arbeitsgruppe auch so als Spielzeug. Der erste Bestell ist halt, wir spielen mal damit rum, was damit geht und was auch nicht geht. Das finde ich schon irgendwie spannend, aber ja ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich meine Leiste, die da jetzt ist, vermissen werde. Also das werde ich dann rausfinden. Aber das finde ich so, ist das Spannende daran, vielleicht mal irgendwie etwas Neues.
Nee, oder doch?
Das ist ein Butterfly-Keyboard.
Nein, das ist nicht das Butterfly. Nee, das ist doch in diesem MacBook One-Port drin. Das ist so das Einzige, wo ich sagen würde, dieses Keyboard ist einem Pro-Gerät einfach nicht würdig. Egal, ob da jetzt Funktionstasten und eine Escape-Taste sind oder nicht, aber die Tasten sind einfach einem Pro-Gerät nicht würdig. Ja, ich habe es mir halt im Apple Store angeguckt und habe da drauf rumgetippt und dachte nur, sie haben halt 1,5 mm Tastenhub gefühlt. Ich meine, klar, Notebook-Tasten hatten nie den großen Tastenhub von einer externen Tastatur.
Von der guten alten IBM, wie heißt das mal?
Naja, inzwischen ist der Tastenhub bei allen Tastaturen geringer geworden, aber das ist halt noch mal so ein Schritt, wo du das Gefühl hast, von gedrückt zu nicht gedrückt, das ist irgendwie und auch so richtig Druckpunkt haben sie nicht. Also wenn du da drauf wirklich tippen willst, ne, sind mir Knöpfe als Tasten.
Ja, dann ist ja auch noch die Frage, wenn ich das Ding auf Arbeit stehen habe, habe ich eigentlich eh immer die externe Tastatur dran. Das ist halt noch so das nächste.
Das ist noch mal was anderes, aber dann hast du halt auch die TouchBar nicht mehr.
Ja genau, das ist halt noch das nächste, wo ich mir dann auch immer so denke, so hm. Aber das finde ich wirklich mal spannend, mit dieser TouchBar irgendwie rumzuprobieren, was sie so kann, was man damit machen kann, könnte.
Habt ihr dieses Video gesehen, was auch so ein bisschen nach dieser Präsentation, nach dieser mega wahnsinnig spannenden Präsentation gepostet wurde, wo Steve Jobs so aus alten Zeiten interviewt wurde zum Thema, was passiert, wenn Product People die Company übernehmen?
Die Tonerheads.
Die Tonerheads und so. Falls die Leute das nicht gesehen haben. Was, wieso ist denn das hier ein Pick?
Hat das jetzt noch mit der TouchBar zu tun?
Das hat mit diesem ganzen, für mich, MacBook und so weiter und was Apple für Produkte gerade macht, zu tun.
Aber wir wollten doch jetzt über das TouchBar reden.
Ja, hier, ich pack den Link trotzdem mal in den Chat.
Also ich finde den TouchBar auch interessant, weil es mal was Neues und ich glaube, dass auch Apple noch gar nicht so richtig erahnen kann, was die Developer demnächst damit so anstellen werden, weil es ja ein Display ist, man kann ja alles Mögliche mitmachen. Und ich finde das auch ziemlich spannend. Vor allem mit der Tatsache, dass halt diese Apples, was ich eigentlich immer schade fand, die haben ja überhaupt keine LED für, früher jedenfalls, deine Festplatte tut irgendwas, was ja ein Indiz war irgendwie, muss man halt eben nicht mehr sein Ohr drauflegen, sondern du hättest das gesehen, oder für ein Netzwerk oder für irgendwas. Und das könnte man jetzt wieder virtuell auf diesen Dingen darstellen. Ich weiß, Apple will das nicht. Die wollen ja, dass du da nur Sachen darstellst, die man auch als Input-Device benutzt. Aber Apple kann sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht dagegen wehren, was die Developer demnächst mit diesem Touch-Ding so machen werden. Zum Beispiel. Icedat-Menu, sag ich nur. Oder dann hier auch Touch-ID zum Öffnen, also dass wir eben nicht irgendwie hier, wie die meisten Leute, so ein 5-Buchstaben-Passwort nehmen, was in 0,0 nichts weggeknackt wird, sondern Touch-ID. Okay, wenn jetzt auch viele sagen, wird auch weggeknackt, aber...
Was mir aufgefallen ist, also du hattest ja dieses Touché in Anschlag gebracht, wo jemand tatsächlich diese Touchbar-Simulationen aus Xcode irgendwie nachprogrammiert hat und man kann sie jetzt einfach runterladen und anmachen.
Nee, da ist nichts nachprogrammiert worden, sondern wenn ich das richtig verstehe, sieht dieses Touchbar-Interface API vor, dass du so eine Art Display-Modus aktivieren kannst. Nach dem Motto hier, ich kümmere mich darum, dass das angezeigt wird.
Nee, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist nach, ich sag mal, nach 5 Minuten...
Wir sollten kurz erwähnen, was wir meinen. Das ist irgendwie von...
Touché heißt das, von Redsweater.
Genau, redsweater.com, das ist Daniel Jalkut, der auch einiger Zeit Mars-Edit übernommen hat, der auch podcastet im Übrigen, wenn es nicht schafft.
Schon in Nekst-Zeiten aktiv gewesen, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Der ist wirklich sehr lange dabei schon. Nee, was mir aufgefallen ist, du machst dann irgendein Programm an, es zeigt dann irgendwelche Tasten und du gehst ganz automatisch mit dem Mauszeiger drüber und wartest auf diesen Tooltip, was bedeutet diese Taste. Und dass mir das nach zehn Minuten passiert ist, zeigt für mich, dass es schwierig wird, für diese ganzen Icons auf dieser Bar klar zu werden, was tun diese Tasten. Also einerseits hast du jetzt den Vorteil, dass die Funktionen, die irgendwie in dem Zusammenhang, in dem du dich gerade befindest, dass die jetzt plötzlich da sind und dass die discoverable sind. Andererseits hast du keine Ahnung, was diese Icons sollen. Das ist irgendwie immer das Problem von Icons.
Aber Tooltips ist jetzt auch nicht, dass es diese schon seit 30 Jahren gibt, sondern die wurden auch irgendwann erst später erfunden.
Aber seit 20.
Ja, aber du bist vorher auch ohne Tooltips klargekommen. Dann werde ich ja wieder.
Ja, aber es gibt einen Grund, warum sich Tooltips durchgesetzt haben.
So oft benutzt man den nicht, wenn das Programm gut ist und einigermaßen intuitiv, dann braucht man keine Tooltips.
Tooltips haben sich durchgesetzt.
Ja doch, wenn Programme nur so halbschlecht sind, also schlecht genug, dass ich nicht durchblicke, aber sie nicht so schlecht sind, dass sie keine Tooltips haben, dann sind sie ganz praktisch.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt, das ist jetzt blöd, dass ich mit Microsoft Office komme, aber halt so Programme, die halt sehr groß sind, sehr viele Funktionen haben und diese sehr vielen Funktionen auf sehr vielen Tasten haben, wenn die wirklich nur Icons haben, dann kommst du sehr schnell an den Punkt und denkst dir, das sind aber schöne Icons und was tun die bitte?
Das geht mir immer bei der F3-Taste so. Das habe ich heute bei jemandem gesehen, das mir so, aha, spannend. Weil ich immer so aktive Ecken habe und damit halt schneller bin.
Ich finde die voll schlimm. Nee, geht gar nicht. Schon gar nicht oben, links und oben, rechts.
Doch, oben, rechts hier für Desktop sehen. Rechts oben.
Rechts oben Desktop, genau.
Nee, ich hab nur rechts unten Screensaver lock und links unten Screensaver auf keinen Fall anmachen.
Ich hab gerade nur rechts oben aktiviert.
Und du machst wieder den Jungs nicht im Griff hier, ne?
Du, das ist schon das zweite 5 Mark Stück, was du heute loben geworden bist. Das dritte fast.
Die gibt es ja zum Glück nicht mehr.
Ich hätte dir so ein Dollarstück aus Ecuador mitbringen können.
Hauptsache, aber nicht.
Jetzt läuft's.
Ich will euch überhaupt gar kein Filmchen zeigen. Ich hab hier auf diesem Computer hier, wenn ich mich gerade rumspiele, hab ich halt dieses Touché, um nochmal klar zu erzählen, was das eigentlich tut.
Kannst du das mal auf dem Beamer tun?
Nein, kann ich nicht, weil das nur auf diesem iMac ist. Das ist jetzt hier nicht an dem anderen Computer dran.
Aber kannst du das größer machen?
Touché größer machen?
Kannst du auch mit Airplay überspielen?
Nein, ich müsste hier...
Oder Retina-Modus umschalten, das ist alles doppelt so groß?
Geht aber.
Clemens, lasst du dir jetzt einen...
Noch ein paar blöde Vorschläge.
Nee, das ist ein guter Vorschlag, tatsächlich.
Was, Airplay oder Retina?
Wenn ich zu Hause meinen Riesendisplay als Fernseher nutze, dann mache ich da Retina-Modus. Dann ist alles richtig groß und lässt sich easy bedienen, obwohl du ein bisschen weiter wegsitzt.
Genau, dann muss man hier mit Option aus Geld gehen. Genau, hier und dann...
Dann muss ich jetzt diese halbe Auflösung auswählen. Und dann, genau, da. Guck hier, extra für dich.
Ah, super. Da kann ja selbst ich noch was sehen.
Nee, und das ist schon...
Also...
Gut, die Einschränkungen in dieser Bewertung hatten wir ja letztes Mal auch schon gemacht. Ist halt nur auf dem Keyboard und hast ein anderes Keyboard, ein externes Keyboard, etc., einen anderen Computer. Hast du es halt nicht. Aber, was ich schon interessant finde, ist, dass sie halt damit ja so ein User-Interface schaffen, im Sinne von die Dinge, die jetzt gerade in diesem Modus, in dem sich die Software befindet, die du gerade benutzt...
Kontextsensitiv sozusagen.
Die, die sich hier am meisten anbieten oder am häufigsten gebraucht werden, die sind dann da. Das ist schon sehr cool und ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein anderes Verständnis von diesen Funktionstasten, die ja in der Regel eher so applikationsglobal sind. Mag sein, dass ein F-irgendwas nicht in allen Modi des Programms auch wirklich irgendwas tut, meistens sind diese Funktionstasten entweder systemglobal oder in der Regel zumindest abglobal.
Und wenn nicht, dann hast du immer unten am Fenster diese Leiste, wo erklärt wird, welche Funktionstaste gerade was tut, so Norton Commander mäßig.
Genau, oder es macht einfach Bing, Bing, Bing, Nein, Nein, Nein, Nein, so und das ist hier schon anders. Ich hab hier immer Final Cut Pro aufgerufen und wenn ich dann halt hier in der Timeline in so einem Video rumfummel, dann krieg ich halt hier angeboten. So und jetzt hätt ich auch ganz gerne Tooltip, das stimmt schon aber auch nur, weil es auf dem Bildschirm ist, wo es ja normalerweise nicht hingehört. Aber ich hab halt hier so eine Trim-Funktion und Was ist das jetzt da? Abschneiden-Funktion. Einfach jetzt mal in der Annahme, dass das eben so die offensichtlichsten oder populärsten Sachen sind und außerdem gibt es ja noch diese Möglichkeit, das zu customisieren.
Das ist jetzt hier leider...
Und da gibt es dann vielleicht auch die Tooltips.
Das ist jetzt hier...
Ich wüsste nicht, wie ich diesen Customizer hier aufrufe.
Mach mal Force-Touch auf das.
Das Menü ist ja von Final Cut Pro, das weiß ja nichts davon. Das heißt, wenn das da ist, hast du schon recht.
Wobei, haben die nicht gesagt, dass Final Cut Pro Touch-Things kommt erst noch?
Nee, das ist hier alles drin.
Achso, für Logic oder für diese andere Audioprogramm haben sie gesagt, kommt dann irgendwie erst noch.
Ja, und Adobe lässt sich wahrscheinlich wieder richtig Zeit.
Also, keine Ahnung. Das ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, wo das auftauchen sollte.
Da haben sie eigentlich was gesagt, ob man das mit jeder Programmiersprache ansteuern kann oder nur Sachen, die mit Xcode und Swift gibt.
Alles, was du nach Objective-C oder Swift casten kannst. Dann musst du halt eine Bridge schreiben. Es ist Coco. Natürlich kannst du nicht, wenn du irgendwie mit Qt oder mit irgendeinem anderen abstrusen Framework...
Flash!
Genau, deine Grafik machst. Dann kannst du natürlich nicht die ganzen Mechanismen von Coco benutzen.
Letty möchte das gerne in Logo machen und ihre kleine Turtle aus der TouchBar bringen. Stimmt's?
Da hätte ich gar nicht dran gedacht. Ich überleg gerade, wie so ein Interface für Prolog aussehen würde.
Ein Interface für Prolog?
Ja, auf dem TouchBar.
Ja, da ist die Do oder Min-Taste. Prolog geht doch immer vom Ergebnis aus. Das ist doch schon mal ganz sinnvoll. Das ist ja im Prinzip wie Erlang.
Vom Ergebnis ausgehen?
Na ja, du schreibst halt immer einen... Wie nennt sich das bei Erlang noch? Ich weiß nicht Ich weiß nicht Jedes Statement in Erlang ist ein... Was ist nochmal der korrekte Term dafür? Ich krieg's grad nicht zusammen.
Expression?
Es heißt nicht Expression.
Ah, ich programmier jetzt schon seit drei Monaten nicht mehr. Ist jetzt gerade auch nicht griffbereit.
Aber das haben sie sich ja im Prinzip von Prolog abgeguckt. Also die Inspiration, auch der Syntax von Erlang, ist halt Prolog. Bin ich jetzt auch gerade nicht vorbereitet für meinen eigenen Gedankenblitz. Gut, haben wir noch irgendwas zum Thema TouchBar?
Nicht so direkt, ich hab mir jetzt ja quasi das analoge, also so das, ja ich nehm noch so ein Bierchen. Ja, ich auch. Sozusagen die komplette Antithese dazu gekauft. Nämlich ein Interface, was Hardwired hart gegossen in seine Form für genau ein Anwendungsfall ist. Und zwar ein Audio-Fader, also so ein, hier kennst du vielleicht den Presonus-Fader-Port? Auf den Schirm? Tim? Mach mal auf den Schirm für die anderen. Ist halt für...
Das ist so ein Motor-Fader-Controller.
Genau, ist halt für Audioprogramme-Bearbeitung, ja. Also das, was Tim da in, was weiß ich, 8 oder 16 Kanälen hat. Diese Fader, die fröhlich auf und ab fahren, wenn er da irgendwelche Presets aufruft. Das gibt es halt auch sozusagen für die Leute, die nicht ganz so viel Geld haben, weil diese Dinge halt mega teuer sind, in der einfachen Variante. Hast du einen Fader und halt so Play, Pause, Rekord, Panning, Channel Select und lauter so Buttons, klick mal da drauf, genau. Und das ist quasi genau die Antithese zur TouchBar. Das ist gemacht für diesen Anwendungsfall. Und das Ding ist halt, so Pulte oder Controller mit Motorfader sind einfach mega teuer. Und das Einzige, was bezahlbar ist und zumindest ein Motorfader hat, ist halt dieses Gerät. Es gibt auch sonst keine Konkurrenzprodukte leider.
Schade ist, dass hier alles beschrieben ist. Genau auf sowas habe ich schon länger gewartet. Sowas hätte ich nämlich gerne hier für jede Position hier auf den Dings. Weil dann kannst du damit deinen Kopfhörer, die Lautsäcke regeln und so weiter. Und wenn es halt ein Motorfader hat, dann züngt es sich halt auch. Aber die anderen Buttons muss man halt anders belegen können.
Kann man auch, also zum Beispiel, ich benutze das ja mit Reaper und das ist jetzt nicht offiziell unterstützt. Da sind halt alle großen Audiobearbeitungstools am Start. Aber Reaper war nicht dabei, aber einer im Reaper Forum hat da quasi ein Control-Surface-Plugin für Reaper geschrieben. Und da gibt es halt ein Inifile, was im Prinzip, also Inifiles sind ja Text-Sateien im Wesentlichen, da kannst du halt sozusagen auch alle Parameter umbiegen. Und es sah nicht so mega kompliziert aus. Also vielleicht gibt es auch so etwas so zu USC gemapped oder so. Habe ich aber noch nicht recherchiert. Aber auf jeden Fall diese Reaper-Anbindung funktioniert auch total super. Und ich bin jetzt irgendwie total happy, dass ich quasi so eine Control-Surface habe, genau für diesen Anwendungsfall in Hardware mit echten Knöpfen, mit Fader und Detailet.
Das Bild, was Apple da hatte von der Workstation, wie sie sich das vorstellen, da war glaube ich auch so ein, also entweder das oder so ein ähnliches Ding, auch mit einem einzelnen Fader.
Ja, das war glaube ich auf einem ihrer Audiobearbeitungstische oder so, oder Pro-Setups war das mit dabei. Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt auch sonst nichts anderes mit, also das Problem ist halt, warum Motorfader so geil ist, das war mir auch erst eine lange Zeit nicht klar, weil ich hab mir erst mal so einen Controller gekauft, der keine Motorfader hatte, aber dann wechselt es halt zwischen den Kanälen hin und her und wenn man hat halt öfters auch mal mehr als acht und dann sind die Fader-Positionen, die korrespondieren dann nicht mehr mit dem Softwarezustand.
Alles außer Motorfader ist vollkommen indiskutabel.
Ja, besonders wenn man sie einmal benutzt hat, dann ist es halt Feierabend.
Auch schon davor, auch schon davor.
Davor ist es nervig, wenn du es einmal benutzt hast, ist es komplett indiskutabel.
Wieso? Das war noch fertig. Das passt doch thematisch dazu.
Huckel hat einen Lauf, lass ihn.
Wieso?
Gab es noch was zum Thema TouchBar?
Macht das Ding ja OSC?
Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht verbrieft sagen. Ich würde vermuten, weil das Ding gibt es schon sehr, sehr lange und es gibt so Leute, die alle möglichen Sachen, also Plugins schreiben für alle möglichen Programme und Interfaces und ich würde stark vermuten. Also es würde mich überraschen, sagen wir mal, wenn es da kein OSC.
Genau.
Na doch, es macht ja MIDI, also es macht auch irgendwas mit MIDI. Aber kannst du dann nicht trotzdem...
Der ist von 2007?
Ich habe den irgendwann mal gesehen. Hat der sich geändert?
Firmware hat sich vor allen Dingen geändert, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die hat, wer, keine Ahnung. Also, hat ein USB 1.1-Port würde jetzt darauf hindeuten, dass es nicht geändert hat.
Also hier Native Mode, Reba 4.5.
Na ja, ok, weiß auch immer, was das genau heißt. Ich habe mir jetzt auf jeden Fall dieses Tool von dem User aus dem Forum runtergeladen, weil da eben alles nochmal umdefinierbar ist in so einem schönen Inifile. Bisher klickt sich das oder toucht sich das auf jeden Fall tausendmal besser, als mit der Maus die ganze Zeit rumzuschubsen, beziehungsweise Fader ohne Motor zu haben. Und dieser Pen-Knopf da oben ist auch einer, der unendlich dreht und kann es halt auch so durch die ganzen Channel durch.
Aber der hat keine Lampen.
Der Fader.
Also ein Rotator wird ja erst dann, also das ist ja quasi das Äquivalent zum Motorfader, ist bei den Drehknöpfen, wenn du da so eine LED-Radio drum herum hast, womit du einen Wert anzeigen kannst.
Das hat er leider nicht.
Und die Buttons müssen halt alle leuchten. Ich meine, ich hab ja dieses uralte Behringer BCF, das kennst du ja wahrscheinlich auch.
Das hast du schon mal gesehen.
Das ist ja so ein Klassiker, BCF 2000.
Das sind die Namen, die die ansehen.
Die Namen allein schon.
Also gibt es in der Variante BCF...
Das Schlachtschiff, ja.
Genau, das ist jetzt schon sehr alt und abgehangen, aber hat auch sehr langsame Motorfäder, muss man dazu sagen. Aber ist halt konsequent gebaut. Also alle Buttons haben halt einfach Lampen drin. Und die Rotorknöpfe haben halt auch alle eine LED. Das heißt, du kannst da einfach irgendeinen State reinwerfen. Und er zeigt den einfach korrekt an. Die Motorfäder sind leider langsam und laut. Deswegen sind sie...
Das ganze Ding ist ein bisschen laut, fand ich.
Das Ding ist auch insgesamt einfach ein bisschen klapprig und... Ja, und ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum es davon nicht was tolles, Neues, Schönes gibt.
Das ist das gleiche mit dem Faderpod. Das Ding, wie gesagt, gibt es ja seit 2007. Und der Bedarf gerade so mit Home Studio. Und alle können jetzt ja Audio machen. Und es gibt günstige Interfaces. Und der ganze Markt ist ja die ganze Zeit am Vibrieren. Und es gibt immer was Neues. Aber genau dieses Ding, so eine ordentliche Control-Surface, die gibt es nur billig und klapprig. Faderpod ist jetzt auch nicht der größte Meilenstein der Verarbeitung dieser Erde. Aber es ist schon mal deutlich besser als so Behringer Billo-Standard. Wobei Behringer auch bessere Sachen im Angebot hat. Und dann das nächste Beste fängt dann gleich schon wieder bei ein paar hundert Euro an. Also so 400, 500, 600. Es ist echt komisch, warum es da in diesem Marktsegment noch keiner gewagt hat, mal was Neues, Besseres zu bauen.
Ich glaube, ab einem bestimmten Preis kannst du auch gleich das ganze Mischpult reinbauen.
Ja, wobei, also ich meine, keine Ahnung. Ich würde schon 400, 500 Euro ausgeben, wenn ich dann acht Motorfader hätte und auch so die Verarbeitung und alles so entsprechend wäre. Allerdings, die Geräte, die es zum Beispiel bei Thomann da in der ganzen Liste gibt, die haben dann auch alle sehr, sehr durchmischte Bewertungen, was zum Beispiel die Haltbarkeit der Motorfader angeht oder die... Also bringt ja auch nichts, wenn der dann für zwei Monate gut funktioniert und dann wieder abkackt. Also, aber vielleicht habe ich, ich meine, ich habe auch lange jetzt nicht mehr so eine intensive Marktrecherche gemacht, falls ein Hörer irgendwie einen Tipp hat, für neue Produkte her damit. Aber die, die so aussehen, als würde man sie haben wollen, die kosten dann auch schon eher 1.000 und mehr. Dein Mischpult ist, ich meine, das macht ja sowieso 1.000 andere Sachen noch, aber das ist ja auch so ein 4.000, 5.000, nein, 3.000?
Nee, das ist Yamaha 01V96, das ist ja eigentlich so der VW Golf unter den Digitalmixern.
Neuer Golf kostet auch nicht so wenig.
Und die Abgaswerte stimmen nicht.
Vielleicht mal ganz interessant zu gucken, was eigentlich derzeit der übliche Preis ist. Aber das Ding lag eigentlich jetzt über lange, lange Zeit immer so bei 2.500 Euro, jetzt kriegst du so für 2.000. Auch schon in einer neueren Version, in der E-Version, der hat dann halt auch USB und da kannst du dann auch Multitrack-Recording darüber machen. Das heißt im Prinzip kannst du das, was ich jetzt hier mit dieser Dante-Karte mache, da über USB machen, nur halt mit den üblichen Nachteilen, die USB so mit sich bringt. Nämlich Scheiße und Latenz und so. Aber der 01V ist halt einfach, den findest du einfach überall. Geh in irgendein Veranstaltungszentrum rum, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du da in jedem Raum, bei Default einfach mal so ein Ding stehen hast, ist einfach sehr hoch. Damit kennen sich halt einfach enorm viele Leute aus. Und das ist aber auch mega solider Hardware, die einfach auch nicht so ohne weiteres kaputt geht. Von daher bin ich da nach wie vor sehr, sehr, sehr glücklich. Ich hätte nur gerne das ganze Ding irgendwie mit mehr Ethernet. Gibt es leider nicht.
Ich habe mal eine Frage zwischendurch. Also, nee, das ist schwierig. Ist das kleine Grätsche wieder zurück eigentlich? Bei Usb-C, wenn das Thunderbolt und alles Mögliche macht, dann ist das ja auch so richtig am Bus dran. Also nicht so serieller.
Das ist theoretisch ein PCI-Port.
Das heißt, über alles, was du da anschließt, kriegst du jetzt den RAM. Also du kommst ja an alle dran. Also hier so die ganzen Hacks mit RAM-Auslesen und so rein.
Müsste auch gehen.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das... Das hat mir letztes Mal auch schon angesprochen. Du hättest einfach mal die Sendung hören sollen.
Ich dachte, ihr wisst das jetzt. Ich dachte, ihr habt das jetzt durchgesprochen.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich einen Kommentar überlesen, aber da hat sich irgendwie meines Wissens niemand jetzt noch zu geäußert und ich habe dem jetzt auch nicht sonderlich hinterhergeklickt.
Ja, aber das müsste ja eigentlich bei den alten Ports, also Thunderbolt 1 und 2, ist ja das gleiche Problem, weil es dann die gleiche Prinzip, jetzt ist nur schneller, müsste das ja auch schon sein und wenn da einer geschrieben hat, ja, lässt sich das ganze RAM auslesen, dann lässt sich das RAM auslesen und ich glaube, das war so.
Ich glaube, dass das Problem schon länger irgendwie mit Virtualisierung in irgendeiner Form angegangen ist, aber ich kann es jetzt auch nicht beschwören. Also sonst wäre das ja auch noch ein Thema gewesen.
Aber für Sicherheit interessieren sich die Leute ja nicht so sehr. Die Leute. Facehugger.
Ich bin ja vollkommen, ich dachte ich fall um.
Ich bin vorhin an so einer Facebook Werbung vorbeigelaufen. Richtig. Ja, ich auch. Echt? Ja, die ist krass.
Abonnier keine Poser stand da drauf.
Auf meiner stand so ein Mädel so, das hätte ich nie posten sollen.
Die habe ich auch gesehen am Bahnhof.
Die werben jetzt damit, dass du das im Internet löschen kannst.
Die haben ein PR-Problem sozusagen.
Kommt das jetzt nach dieser Trump-Geschichte? So schnell kann das nicht sein.
Das ist ja nichts Neues. Die Diskussion um Facebook und ihren Community-Regeln, was sie da löschen und was die Leute wirklich können und nicht können, das wird jetzt wohl langsam ein bisschen problematisch.
Was ist denn dir aus dieser Anzeige wegen Volksverhetzung oder Beihilfe zur Volksverhetzung geworden?
So 2024 verhandelt.
Das ist, wenn ich das sehe, vor ein paar zwei Wochen an den Start gegangen. Wenn da jemand angeklagt wird, der noch nicht mal hier ist, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, dass in dem Zeitraum von 40... Ich glaube, in den Tagen sehe ich jetzt noch nicht ganz so viel.
Okay, hätte ja sein können.
Aber abonniert keine Poser. Hab ich so ein bisschen ins Krübeln gekommen. Also, ich dachte, das ist das worum es da geht. Oder? Ist das YouTube?
Das ist YouTube, glaube ich, mit den Posern.
Na ja, das ist doch ein generelles Problem, Leute.
Das ist das Problem mit den Menschen.
Also, ich bin ja auch ein Poser, ne? Ja, aber ich habe...
Hast mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Nee, auf Twitter folgen die ja nur. Nee, bei Podcasts gilt das natürlich auch. Was mich jetzt so ein bisschen verstört hat, ist aber, ist denn der Begriff Poser jetzt ein Problem geworden? Gibt es jetzt auf einmal so eine Kategorie Menschen, die man als Poser nennt und die sind jetzt so gefährlich wie Bankräuber oder irgendwie Islamisten? Oder meinen sie damit, wollen sie dann die Leute, die posen, schützen im Sinne von, gib ihnen nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit, sonst machen die sich fertig?
Du denkst jetzt wirklich über eine Werbung von Facebook nach?
Mich würde interessieren, was da für ein Bild drauf macht.
Klar, weil ehrlich gesagt, ich habe noch nie Werbung von Facebook gesehen, auf Plakat zumindest.
Bisher hatten sie es ja auch nicht nötig.
Ich glaube, ich habe überhaupt noch nie Werbung gesehen. Für mich war das so ein bisschen wie Ende der 80er Jahre, als ich das erste Mal eine Plakatwerbung für Musik gesehen habe. Das gab es nämlich damals auch nicht.
Das stimmt. Aber ich muss sagen, die erste Plakatwerbung für den Google Chrome, da dachte ich auch so, ja, jetzt ist wohl die Kurve am abflachen.
Ja, immerhin Software.
Aber so, egal.
Ist jetzt auf jeden Fall so.
Ich meine gerade, ob dann irgendwo unten eine Link drauf steht mit hier downloaden.
Nein, da drunter stand, was stand da drunter? Irgendwie mach Facebook, irgendwie zu deinem Facebook oder so was. Facehugger.
Lösch dein Content, mach es dein Facebook.
Halte deinen Freundeskreis sauber.
Ist gut, ich nenne jetzt nur noch Facehugger.
Facehugger? Die Fratzenfibel?
Nein, die Facehugger sind ja nicht das Buch.
Ja, ich weiß, was ein Facehugger ist.
Das ist die von Alien?
Ja, die von Alien, die sich so auf das Gesicht drauf legen.
War die nicht auch im Gesicht? Ja, ich glaube ja.
Diese Facehugger, da fing es dann an, unglaublich zu werden.
Was? Alien?
Du willst jetzt behaupten, das wäre nicht wahr oder was? Guck mal, hier Facehugger gibt es sogar mit Plüsch.
Kann man den Kindern ins Gesicht legen, wenn sie terfen?
Kleine Babys mit Facehugger.
Und wo ist es? Bei Facebook hast du gesehen.
Das gibt es auch woanders, aber das ist ziemlich geil. Du kannst dich auf einer Party irgendwo so hinlegen, Facehugger drauf, ein bisschen Blut.
Das wissen die jungen Leute doch ja nicht mehr.
Du meinst du als Schlafbrille im Flugzeug.
Das ist eine ganz gute Idee.
Wenn man es berührt, muss es sich so weiter zusammenziehen um den Hals.
Aber was denn jetzt mit den Posern? Also wollen die jetzt die Poser beschützen? Oder wollen die uns vor Posern beschützen? Geht Gefahr von Posern aus?
Ich glaube, es ist einfach nur ein Image-Ding.
Ja, aber was ist denn da das Image?
Das Image ist, dass Facebook jetzt...
Wir kümmern uns.
We care for you.
Wir seid uns nicht egal und...
Wir sind hier und plakatieren auch in deiner Stadt.
Aber We care for you hat auch schon die BSR behauptet.
Die machen das ja zumindest auch.
Mit einigen Wochen Verzug, aber ja.
Ja, tut halt was man... Wir sind ja in Berlin, ne?
Richtig, ein bisschen unordentlich sein.
Bisschen dreckig, oder irgendwas auch, ne? Früher war es viel dreckiger im Prenzlauer Berg.
Ich bin schon lange nicht mehr in den Hundehaufen gelaufen.
Ja, das Hundehaufenproblem ist im Griff.
Ja, ansonsten würden wir wahrscheinlich...
Die Schwaben stürmen laufen.
Seitdem ist es besser.
Haben die Prenzlberger ihre Hunde durch Kinder ersetzt?
Ja, Facebook. Gut, mehr muss man dazu nicht sagen.
Zum Thema Apple. Ich habe da mal was ganz anderes gemacht. Ich habe auch Hardware angeschafft, weil ich dachte, das mit dem Mac Mini und mit diesem ganzen Krämpel, das wird doch nichts mehr.
Hack-Intausch, Hack-Intausch.
Genau, habe ich mal angefangen, mich an einen Hack-Intausch zu wagen.
Ich dachte schon, dass wir ausgestorben.
Es ist noch viel schmerzhafter, als ich dachte. Also, vor allen Dingen, den USB-Stick zu machen, damit man davon booten kann, das geht ja noch. Da gibt es irgendwie dieses, keine Ahnung, TonyMACX86 hat irgendwie da diese ganze Software rumfliegen.
War es denn schwierig, die Hardware überhaupt zusammengestellt zu bekommen oder hast du das jetzt bei irgendeinem Händler bezogen, der sagt, hier ist schon mal weit geht?
Hast du das Workflow gerade offen? Klick mal den Link zum Thema Skull Canyon. Skull Canyon, ja. Und zwar gibt es von Inter so einen niedlichen Mini-PC, der Skull Canyon genannt wird. Da ist irgendwie so alles drin, was man braucht. Unter anderem auch ein Thunderbolt 3 als Usb-C. Den hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Hier ist ein Usb-C Thunderbolt dran. Genau, den hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert in Ermangelung von Thunderbolt 3 Geräten. Da kann man zwei Speicherriegel und zwei SSDs reintun. Oder was auch immer man sonst in diese komischen M2 PCI Slots reintut. Und dann läuft die Kiste. Jetzt geht's schon los. Das erste, was Mac OS nicht unterstützt, ist PCI-SSD-Karten. Die verbauen die zwar, aber irgendwie hat Apple andere Controller. Oder weiß ich nicht was, die funktionieren also nicht out of the box. Habe ich erstmal die falsche SSD besorgt. Diese Samsung-Dinger, die ganz schnellen, die man eigentlich haben will.
Die EVOs oder ja, genau.
Und dann habe ich irgendwie das dann doch irgendwie zum Booten gekriegt, weil ich dachte, installierst du es erstmal auf einer externen 2,5 Zoll Festplatte. Und dann kommt er halt diese Installationsassistent hoch mit, ja hier Netzwerk, also WLAN habe ich nicht gefunden, habe ich auch ausgeschaltet, unterstützt er sowieso nicht. Aber hier über Ethernet und wollen sie denn DHCP machen? Und ich so, ja mach mal. Klick, bamm, weg war er. Na gut, naja er holt sich dann über DHCP das Netz, über Ethernet einfach so. Hier willst du Ethernet machen? Und ich so, ja mach mal Netzwerk über Ethernet. Und dann macht er halt bamm und bootet neu. Also den Ethernet unterstützt er auch nicht. Und dann habe ich also den mal installiert, ohne alles wirklich nichts anmachen. Dann ist die Installation durchgelaufen. Sierra lief und dann dachte ich, ah jetzt machst du noch ein kleines und das. Neu booten, bootet er neu, gebe ich das Passwort ein, nimmt das Passwort nicht mehr, was ich irgendwie gerade eben erst gesetzt habe. Da dachte ich, habe ich jetzt so ein Huckelmoment und weiß ich jetzt das Passwort nicht mehr. Aber das war es nicht. Also irgendwie und dann habe ich aufgegeben und dann kam so ein Moment, der war wirklich sehr scary. Weil dann dachte ich, na gut, dann installierst du jetzt Windows drauf und mach auf dem MacBook mit diesem Bootcamp-Assistenten einen bootfähigen Windows-Stick, steck den da rein, sag installieren und nach 10 Minuten habe ich ein laufendes Windows. Da dachte ich so, so.
Aber noch kein WLAN, da kommt noch mal eine Stunde dazu.
Nö, nö, das hat alles funktioniert. WLAN hat alles funktioniert, weißt du so. Auch irgendwie so, da habe ich so ein bisschen geguckt, wie ist denn das mit Windows 7, Windows 10 und so weiter. Und dann gab es irgendein heißer Artikel nach, ja, wenn man das einfach bei Microsoft runterlädt und installiert, dann kann man seinen alten Windows 7 Key eingeben und dann nimmt er den einfach und dann hat man irgendwie ein laufiges Windows 10. Hab ich das gemacht, das funktioniert. Und ich dachte so, in welcher Welt bin ich denn hier gerade? Das ist alles irgendwie...
Nein, in der PC-Welt bist du, wo halt Windows funktioniert.
Ja, aber Windows hat nie funktioniert.
Das haben wir mittlerweile schon ganz gut hinbekommen für so Fertigkisten. Also das kann man denen schon mal zuschreiben, aber...
Also es ist ein nettes kleines Rechnerchen, aber das mit dem Hackintosh, das muss man sich gut überlegen, ob man die Geduld hat. Also wir werden das irgendwann nochmal weitermachen.
Also ich finde ja schon mal, wenn du dir so eine fertige Kiste baust, das ist ja nicht so wirklich Hackintosh, ne?
Na ja, Hackintosh ist eigentlich... Ja, du suchst die ganzen Komponenten per Hand zusammen. Aber die fangen halt alle an mit... Ja, und dann kaufst du noch den WLAN-Stick und steckst den in den USB rein, weil dann hast du WLAN und dann noch dieses und jenes und dann denkst du so, äh...
Ja, du kriegst halt keinen Mac, ist schon klar.
Naja, ist schon klar.
Du kriegst halt die PC-Hölle. Mit MacOS-Betriebssystem.
Also ich werd berichten, falls sich da irgendwie noch mal was tut. Aber momentan, das mit dem MacOS auf dem Ding war jetzt erstmal nicht so erfolgreich.
Müssen wir also doch diese blöde Apple-Hardware weiter kaufen, ne?
Vielleicht hat er sich auch nicht mit den 32 GB vertragen.
Ja, das kann er ja gar nicht unterstützen.
Oh, jetzt kommt Tims nächste Themenkarte.
Die er aus einer Schublade hervorzaubert.
Trommelwirbel.
Ja, wir haben eigentlich noch mehr zum Thema Mac zu erzählen. Ihr kennt ja sicherlich diese großartigen iFixit Teardowns alle. Und das Business-Modell davon ist ja...
Werkzeugverkaufen. Pentalob-Schraubenzieher.
Genau, genau.
Du bist in diese Falle getappt jetzt.
Ich bin jetzt in diese Falle getappt, weil ich nämlich auch einen Schraubbedarf hatte.
Du Opfer. Schraubbedarf.
Ja, ich musste meinen MacBook Air mal aufmachen, oder wollte das zumindest, weil ich hab da vor einiger Zeit mal Clubmater reingegossen und es war irgendwie nicht so geil.
Hat es nicht besser gemacht.
Hat es nicht sofort spürbar verbessert, richtig? Und es war undramatisch insofern, als dass es nur mein Trackpad betraf und es auch nur verklebt hat. Ich dachte erst, jetzt muss ich das irgendwie in Alkohol einlegen oder sonst irgendwas, aber es war einfach genug, das Ding einfach mal auseinanderzubauen und das Trackpad zu isolieren, sauber zu machen, reinbauen, zusammenschrauben. Fertig ist die Laube. Aber dann dachte ich mir, nehme ich gleich mal den Boltmove und habe mir mal dieses komplette iFixit Repair Kit.
Du hast aber auch die ganz dicke Version geschoppt, oder?
Ja, klar, keine Gefangenen.
Tim halt. iFixit rechts unten.
Ich hätte von dem Preis jetzt ein neues Air kaufen können, fast. Aber kostet schon 60 Euro. Das war die kleine Version, oder? Was kostet das? 120?
Nee, so 60 Euro.
Also ist das doch die normale Version, oder wie?
Genau, also klappst du es so auf.
Und dann ist da halt vor allem erstmal so eine dicke, fette Box drin mit vielen Bits.
Eine Bitkiste.
Eine Bitkiste, wo...
Ich würde sogar sagen Bits und so.
Also hast du hier vor allem halt auch immer alles in sehr klein. So hast du halt hier so die üblichen Kreuzschlitzgeschichten.
Phillips meinst du? Phillips heißen die?
Es gibt ja Phillips und die anderen.
Die heißen auch Kreuzschlitz, so ist es nicht.
Aber es gibt zwei Kreuze, aber es gibt nur einen Phillips.
Ja, PH und PZ oder so ähnlich. PZ, genau. PH ist halt Phillips. Anyway, hier gibt es dann auch noch das alles in dreieckig. Dann gibt es das alles in dreiecksig. Was ist denn dreiecksig?
Die sind mit den drei Schnupsis halt.
Also ein Dreierstern. So wie es ein Fünferstern gibt, gibt es halt ein Sechserstern. Das ist halt Torx. Pentalobe ist halt Fünf. Und hier gibt es auch noch ein Dreierstern. Dann gibt es halt irgendwie Torx. Incorrekt. Natürlich Schlitze.
Gibt es auch Sicherheits. Haben die Löcher? Also kann man ja für Security-Torx benutzen.
Torx gibt es auch hier noch einmal komplett mit Löchern in verschiedenen Größen. Dann gibt es...
Also wer das jetzt so mitgucken will, dann muss einfach bei iFixit, da kann man die ja auch alle finden.
Ja, Torx mit Loch und so. Und dann Vierkant gibt es auch noch. Und dann auch noch diese, die du auch von Zeit zu Zeit findest, diese Schlitze mit Loch in der Mitte.
Wo du nur so zwei Pins hast, die du irgendwo reinsteckst.
Wo du links und rechts so zwei, genau so ein bisschen wackenmäßig. Dann auch ein paar Inbus-Köpfe und so weiter.
Eher wie die Sicherung früher im Auto.
Also ich kann es jetzt nicht beschwören, aber ich würde mal sagen, damit kommst du so in aktuelle Elektronik, die irgendwie verschraubt ist, kommst du damit rein. Dazu hast du einen relativ qualitativ hochwertigen Griff. Schön oben mit durchrotierendem Kopf und alles natürlich ordentlich magnetisch. Und sellenmäßig dabei auch gleich noch ein Verlängerungselement, was biegsam ist. Also kannst du es auch um die Ecke schrauben. Was ja schon mal ganz cool ist. Dazu gibt es dann die üblichen Spezial-Dinger, die du heutzutage für den Computerauseinanderbau brauchst. Also Saugnapf mit Ringen, dann diese typischen Plasteprokel-Dinger, um so Gehäuse aufzumachen.
Prying Tool, glaube ich.
Genau, Prying Tool. Und dann aber auch noch so ein paar ganz allgemeine so einen Spatel und dann auch noch so diese etwas spitzeren Plasteteile. Alles sehr praktisch, gerade um so kleine Laschen hochzuklappen, wenn du so diese Tastatur-Flachband-Kabel-Dinger hast, wo du dann irgendwo so eine kleine Verankerung lösen musst und hochklappen musst. Da musst du ja dann sehr genau treffen. Dafür sind die sehr gut gemacht. Und dann halt noch so Pinsetten in zwei verschiedenen Varianten. Und ich habe gerade vergessen, wie man diese X-gekreuzte Pinsette, also die du nicht zusammen, sondern auseinanderdrückst, was den Vorteil hat, dass du damit halt eine Schraube nehmen kannst und ohne weiter Druck auszuüben, hält das Ding, die Schraube dann oder was auch immer, in dem Moment selber fest. Und dann halt hier diese Plektron-artigen Plasteschnupsis auch zum Öffnen von Gehäuse.
Ja, hab ich im Gitarrenladen mir gleich geholt, hab ich die gesehen, dachte ich, die brauche ich zum Rechner öffnen. Kann man in verschiedenen Stärken kaufen auch, ne?
Also es ist ordentlich, muss ich sagen. Es ist mir nicht so leicht gefallen, ich hab schon ein paar Mal versucht, mal so ordentliches Computerbesteck zu kaufen, einfach so im normalen Laden. Also find mal was, was irgendwie ordentlich bestückt ist und auch ordentliche Qualität hat. Und ich finde, da haben die eine ganz interessante Marktnische besetzt damit.
Freunde der Apple-Sperrtechnik.
Genau, jetzt hab ich viel Spaß da dran. Vor allem, ich war natürlich auch sehr gespannt, wie gut sind eigentlich diese Teardowns? Also ich weiß, dass ich früher das schon mal gemacht hab, aber jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit nicht mehr. Und muss sagen, das ist schon ziemlich geil. Also die achten echt aufs Detail, die Fotos sind wirklich brillant und auch hochauflösend, dass du irgendwie die Stellen gut finden kannst und so.
Und wir sagen auch, welche Schraube welche ist und so.
Genau, wie lang die ist, dass du danach wieder gut auseinanderhalten kannst.
Ich frag mich, ob die die Dinge vorher immer röntgen, damit sie dann beim Teardown in der richtigen Reihenfolge auseinanderschrauben. Jaja, schon, aber wenn du irgendwas erst mal kaputt gemacht hast, dann machst du ja kein Schönes.
Die röntgen die ja eh.
Da hat man einfach mal fünf gekauft.
Ja gut, aber jetzt tun sie es halt eh. Von daher kann es durchaus sein, dass sie das auch als erstes machen.
Huckel, tut dir nicht weh.
Ich denke, die haben vor allem einfach eine Menge Erfahrung.
Ja, das ist was für dich.
Ist ja gerade so ein bisschen an den Ärztekoffer.
Original I Fix It Black.
Jaja, davon hat es was.
Wir haben ja im Club auch so ein Set, jetzt nicht ganz so wie deins, aber ich glaube, damals hat es den gleichen Preis gekostet, aber ich glaube, es sind ein paar Teile weniger drin. Von der Qualität war ich nicht so richtig überzeugt. Wobei da der eigentliche, das Drehtool, was bei dir glaube ich aus Plastik war, haben wir sogar noch richtig aus Metall und alles. Aber das ist auch nicht das Entscheidende, sondern die Bits kamen mir nicht so richtig super toll vor. Aber vielleicht müssen die für ein Laptop auch nicht so super toll sein. Ansonsten sind Bits halt auch immer mal schnell kaputt. Und wenn die Bits kaputt sind, dann geht die Schraube kaputt. Und wenn die Schraube rund ist, dann ist halt vorbei. Dann darfst du da aufbohren, machen, tun und so weiter. Deswegen Bits müssen immer ziemlich gut sein.
Das fand ich immer am schrecklichsten eigentlich, dass die meisten Sachen schlechte Bit-Qualität hatten.
Aber Schrauben rund, das liegt ja nicht unbedingt nur an den Bits.
Na doch, aber wenn die so ausbröseln?
Ja, aber die Schrauben können ja auch aus scheiß Material sein.
Ja, das auch, aber dann bleibt das Bit-Fallteil. Aber wenn du ein kaputtes Bit hast, dann machst du die Schraube gleich mit kaputt, wenn du das weiter benutzt. Da muss man zumindest ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, die fühlen sich hier aber erstmal ganz ordentlich aus.
Also es war auch sehr präzise, muss ich sagen, das Schraub-Feeling. Also auch so die kleinsten Talks, das saß richtig satt und hatte Grip und da sprang nichts über. Das ist natürlich auch ein Vorteil, dass in diesem Teardown, die halt von vornherein sagen, du brauchst genau das, das, das Werkzeug und jetzt go ahead. Dann war das irgendwie easy, das auseinanderzubauen und jetzt werde ich auch weitere Maßnahmen ergreifen lassen. Ich werde nämlich die Akkus mal tauschen hier mit Third Party, weil von Apple kann man jetzt glaube ich eh nicht mehr so sehr viel erwarten. Erstens ist glaube ich der Service jetzt auch abgelaufen. Also die unterstützen das Gerät jetzt auch gar nicht mehr, was ich habe.
Das habe ich neulich bei einem ersten Generation Air auch mal gemacht.
Das kann ich mir aber gar nicht vorstellen.
Das war gar nicht so fürchterlich schwierig.
Ja, vor allem ich war überrascht irgendwie, ich kriege das irgendwie für...
Wann ist denn das?
Das ist 2013.
Weil meins ist noch supported. Also für Ersatzteile und so. Und das ist von 2012.
Vor 5 Jahren machen sie mal danach, schmeißen eine eventuell raus. Manchmal auch 6.
Oder vielleicht täusche ich mich, 2011. Da gibt es ja so eine Webseite beim Apfel, die kennt irgendwie auch nicht jeder. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile schon wieder, ich wollte gerade sagen, ob das wieder mit irgendwas zusammengelegt ist, in diesem Moment gibt es hier wieder redirect. We've upgraded our support tools. Aha, okay, ich wollte gerade pluggen, ich habe hier ein Support profile.apple.com und jetzt, was? Jetzt schicken sie mich auf getsupport.apple.com.
Ach, guck an.
Aber man kann sich hier noch einloggen. Hallo, wo ist mein Support Profile? Es geht bergab.
Das Ding fühlt sich nicht so gut an.
Das ist die Inverse Pinzette.
Wieso fühlt sich das nicht gut an?
Na, weil die hier reibt, weil die da aufeinanderschleift. Man könnte sie auseinander drücken, und dann macht sie auch keine Geräusche mehr. Das heißt, du müsstest die Nummer biegen, aber dann ist die oben halt nicht mehr in Sync.
Nichts mal präziser verarbeiten.
Aber so wie das aussieht, sind die Pinzettenköpfe festgeschraubt. Das heißt, man könnte sie so verändern.
Aber es macht schon einen sehr schnuffigen Eindruck. Auf jeden Fall für diese speziellen Schrauben-Kombinationen. Ich hab ja eigentlich auch das typische Sammelsorium an Werkzeugen. Habt ihr ja alle so einen Werkzeugkoffer voll mit Zeug, das hat man so über die Jahre immer so anschafft, wenn man was braucht.
Einen?
Das ist mehrere. Ich hab einen großen Werkzeugkoffer.
Wir haben keinen großen.
Hab ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber das ist alles verliebend.
Ich hab lauter so Boxen, wo irgendwie das ordentlich drin ist.
Also mein letztes Werkzeug, was ich ja toll fand, hab ich ja auch hier glaub ich erwähnt, war ja von Proxxon. Da fand ich auch so die Inbus-Schlüssel, die Torx-Schlüssel und die Schraubendreher sehr sehr schön. Aber das ist hier auch schön. Will noch jemand grabbeln?
Von wem fandest du das auch schön?
Aber die haben halt jetzt nicht so ein, die haben zum Beispiel ein super cooles so Kfz-Schrauber-Set.
Wenn wir schon ein paar Namen in die Runde schmeißen, ich hab Bosch und Wirt.
Aber nur die blaue Serie von Bosch.
Entschuldigung.
Noch jemand ein Werkzeug-Grabbel in die Mitte in der Runde? Fertig gegrabbelt.
Wobei vielleicht doch, vielleicht kann ich das für die Nähmaschine auch nutzen.
Denkbar. Ich weiß nicht, was hast du denn da so für?
Genau, du kannst ja so ein Kleid mal zusammenschrauben, und nicht immer nur nehmen.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, mit den Schrauben so am...
Den Dennis muss man ihm lassen.
Vielleicht könnten wir ein paar Schrauben dann in dein Einhornkostüm einab.
Mach ihm mal was richtig Hübsches, Letty.
Das sieht schon auch ganz gut aus da.
Wenn die das macht, besorge ich mir ein Wadidubi.
Also ich sehe gerade von Proxxon gibt es den Super-Sicherheits- und Spezialbesatz 75 teilig. Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus, so von der Kollektion her wie...
Da ist aber kein Pentalobe dabei, wetten.
Na ja, da sind aber zumindest die drei beinigen...
Triwing heißen die Dinge.
Diese Pentalobe. Wie sehen die aus, die Pentalobe? Kann ich das noch mal sehen bitte?
Sternchen.
Fünfzackiger Stern.
War nicht Pentalobe mit so Rundung, der sah aus wie eine Prieblume, nur fünf?
Ich dachte auch.
Guck dir an, da hast du doch gerade eine Hand gehabt.
Hast du den Ruf geguckt oder was?
Ich finde den glaube ich am schönsten.
Den saugt nach.
Pentalobe ist rund, wie eine Prieblume, nur fünf, nicht vier.
Missbusted.
Also wenn ich die ganzen Dinger sehe, dann fällt mir diese XKCD zum Thema Standards ein. So und so viele konkurrierende Standards. Lass uns einen neuen Standard machen. Irgendwie gibt es wohl auch bei Maschinenfahrern.
Naja, das ist halt so, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt mit diesen, das ist ja Kraftübertragung, was die da betreiben. Dann gibt es ja auch schon Deswegen Talks, zum Beispiel, weil es halt nochmal irgendwie fünf oder zehn Prozent mehr Kraft übertragen kann als Kreuzschlitz oder weißt schon. Und deswegen gibt es da immer mal wieder neue. Und dann sind die auch noch patentiert, deswegen müssen andere Firmen sich neue einfallen lassen. Aber insgesamt geht es darum, möglichst viel Kraft zu übertragen, ohne dabei kaputt zu gehen. Und Bentalob soll wohl toll sein. Oder auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Nee, aber Talks war ein Stück besser als die davor.
Und diese ganzen Kreuzschlitz-Mumpitz, das können wir da einfach echt mal sein lassen. Das hat nie was gebracht. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es überhaupt so lange gedauert hat. Ich denke, das hat einfach was mit einfach mit der Qualität der ganzen Schrauben- und Werkzeugherstellung zu tun. Ich meine, früher war ja alles Schlitz. Kreuzschlitz war ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon eine Revolution. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, in den 80er Jahren Kreuzschlitzschrauben, also beißt mich aus.
Nein, 80er Jahren gab es schon Kreuz.
Ja, gab es schon.
Aber es war jetzt nicht so präsent.
Mein Amiga war Kreuzschlitz.
Und mittlerweile ist es so, Ja, meiner auch.
Mittlerweile ist es so, dass sogar Ikea jetzt auf Talks sitzt. Echt? Ich habe jetzt neulich mal etwas bei Ikea abgeschleppt und dachte, ich gucke nie recht.
Die hatten noch die ganze Zeit Inbus, ne?
Ja, Inbus haben sie auch immer noch viel, aber sie haben halt viel Kreuzschlitz gehabt.
Sehr viel.
Und jetzt hatte ich so ein...
Was war denn das überhaupt?
Billy.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr. Auf jeden Fall Talks.
Echt, ich habe gerade erst was gekauft, das war noch Kreuz.
Ich sage nicht, Sie haben schon alles umgestellt, aber das sah mir sehr danach aus, nach wir machen das jetzt mal anders, weil Leute sind frustriert von durchgedrehten Schraubenköpfen. Und das sind sie halt auch. Das ist ja dann am Ende auch Ikeas Problem. Und dann war das lustig, weil in der Bedienungsanleitung, die ja immer versucht, ohne Worte auszukommen, mussten sie ja dann halt irgendwie auch abbilden, wie dieser Adapter sozusagen zu sehen ist. Ich erinnere mich jetzt leider an das Bild nicht mehr, aber es war irgendwie ganz lustig. Auf jeden Fall haben sie diesen Aufwand gemacht. Hier, es gibt einen Aufsteckadapter. Wenn du nur Kreuz hast, gab es sozusagen einen Kreuz-auf-Torx-Adapter.
In der Packung?
In der Packung.
Den habe ich doch glaube ich in meinem Werkzeugkoffer sogar.
Kreuz-auf-Torx-Adapter?
Ja, von Ikea, stimmt. Nicht in meinem guten, Werkzeugkoffer.
Sehr krass, hier bei Proxxon gibt es auch die Knüppelgratsche.
Ja, Viertelzoll.
Knüppelgratsche.
Knüppelgratsche, richtig geil.
Und warum hast du nicht die von iFixit, die Deluxe Edition geholt, hier mit dem Holzkasten?
Knüppelgratsche, kannst du das mal in den Spread grafen?
Knüppelgratsche, hat sie mir jetzt angeraten.
Und was meinst du bei iFixit?
Also da hätte ich die 20 Euro noch draufgelegt. Das sieht echt geil aus.
30 Euro.
Oh, 30, aber komm.
Das Universal Bitkit kostet ja allein das Bitkit schon 90 Euro. Das nenne ich 30 Euro mehr.
Und da sind die anderen Tools nicht dabei, ne?
Nee, da sind die ganzen anderen Tools nicht dabei.
Na ja, aber so ein Pnöpel zum Saugen, das findet man doch anders.
Aber ein Universal Bitkit.
Aber das ist schon wirklich was Schönes.
Pnöpel zum Saugen, da war ja noch diese ganzen Plasse-Hebel und so weiter dabei.
Und die Plek drin.
Ja, aber das sieht schon schick aus.
Ja, man kann da beliebig viel Geld ausgeben und ich bin mir auch sicher, dass ich morgen auch diesen blöden Gutscheincode von denen finde, damit die nicht mehr nochmal 10 Euro sparen können und nicht nur irgendwo für Trollen ist.
Passend, oder?
Ich finde ja sehr schön, dass Sie ein 64-Bit-Driver-Kit anbieten.
Humor haben Sie auf jeden Fall.
Und der Eye-Opener ist auch nicht schlecht.
Süchen.
Die haben sogar eine Bürste. Das sieht aus wie das, was man beim Boldern nutzt. Auch interessant.
So wollen wir mal aufs...
Aufs Wesentliche jetzt.
Zum Internet umschalten.
Aufs Internet umschalten. Welches Internet hätten Sie denn gern?
Ach, ich fand nur diese Meldung so geil. Fiel mir irgendwie so auf Future Zone entgegen. Ist jetzt keine besondere Überraschung. Fand ich aber irgendwie sehr sportlich, dass es wohl irgendwie eine Security Vulnerability in diesen Philips-U-Lampen gibt.
Na gut, ist jetzt...
Nicht sonderlich überraschend. Ich meine, die haben irgendwie...
Internet of Terror, oder wie hieß das?
Internet of Terror, genau. Die haben da nämlich halt WLAN drin in diesen Dingern. Und die hängen halt überall rum. Und die werden ja auch fleißig gekauft, wie es so den Einschalt hat. Und außerdem haben die auch noch dieses Zigbee. Jetzt bin ich mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob diese Philips U-Lampen beides haben oder entweder oder haben. Ihr wisst es auch nicht.
Ich habe gar keine Philips U.
Mit diesem Incest of Things beschäftige ich mich gar nicht.
Also wenn ich diesem Artikel folge, war die Lücke halt in diesem Funkstandard, in diesem Zigbee drin. Und das ist irgendwie die Vernetzung, die die Lampen untereinander verwenden. Und das Coole ist, sie haben jetzt nicht nur einen Explode gemacht für diese Security-Lücke. Nein, sie haben dann sozusagen den Rechner, der das ausnutzt, auf eine Drohne montiert und sind dann halt sozusagen durch die Stadt geflogen und haben dann so massenhaft Philips U.-Lampen aufgebracht. Da gibt es ja auch ein schönes Video dazu, wo wir so an einem Haus vorbei sind. Wo wir so mehrere Lampen haben und die Wände halt irgendwie kontrolliert alle aus- und angeschaltet. Was halt schon irgendwie ein ziemlich cooler Hack ist.
Ja, hier Blinken-Lights, Redux.
Ja, klar. Aber es ist natürlich auch mega spooky. Ich meine, hat irgendeiner von euch schon so ein bisschen IoT-Technologie am Start?
Ich darf es nicht sagen, aber bei uns in der Wohnung gibt es so eine komische Lampe.
Muss man mal dein Mikro da wieder...
Was zählt denn alles dazu? Eine Fritzbox ist noch kein IoT, oder?
Was mit meiner Waage mit WLAN?
Ist schon ziemlich IoT.
So was hab ich auch.
Da weißt du halt nicht, ob die Waage nicht irgendwie schon vor zwei Wochen irgendwie Clintons E-Mails gehackt hat.
Aber da kann keiner Licht an- und ausschalten oder sonst wie was.
Also selbstverständlich hacken.
Für nur Viagra-Spam verschicken.
Also können sie rumfliegen und machen, aber optisch stehen sie erst mal nix.
Ja gut, aber du bist dann auf einmal die Quelle einer D-Dos-Attacke, weil dieses Ding nicht abgestürmt wird.
Das kann sein, ja.
Und dann wachst du halt morgens auf, weil die Fensterscheiben klirren, und dann steht da halt so ein Swat-Team bei dir im Wohnzimmer und sagt, Herr Ritatte, kommen Sie bitte mit uns mit.
Nee, denn das hat ja ein FreeBSD-Router, der so was irgendwie ganz intelligent sofort natürlich wegfiltert.
Ja, wenn ich wüsste, dass er das macht. Von innen nach außen ist ja alles erlaubt.
Also ich bin glaube ich komplett...
IoT-frei?
IoT-frei. IoT-frei. IoT-frei.
IoT-frei.
Ja, und habe auch vor, das weitestgehend zu bleiben.
Ich habe das nicht unbedingt vor, aber ich habe natürlich da auch so meine Bedenken, weil wenn man sich halt so die Qualität, die Bildqualität und die Softwarequalität dieser Devices, die ja dann auch für lächerliche Summen verkauft werden in dem ganzen China-Gadget-Massaker...
Naja, ich würde dir sagen, das ist ja nicht mal das Problem. Also Software ist schon immer schlecht und hat so mit Updates irgendwie hat man die so...
Wird auch immer so bleiben.
Wird auch immer so bleiben. Und es steht ja hier auch in den Artikel gleich, da unten Patch verfügbar. Das Problem ist halt, wer spielt den halt ein? Also die Leute kümmern sich ja jetzt schon ohne Geld.
Wer will denn auch seine Glühbirnen abschälen?
Und dann rumhacken an so einer Hardware ist ja eigentlich verboten auch. Da haben sie ja auch dicht gemacht, oder? Wie war das? So wie mit den WLAN-Stationen, wo man nicht mehr herumfuschen darf.
Umstritten.
Ja, und dann wird natürlich nichts gefixt. Sonst würde man es ja selber machen oder irgendwer.
Ja, selbst wenn es erlaubt wäre, glaube ich. Also fixen kann es am Ende nur der Hersteller oder die Systemik, in die das alles eingebettet ist. Die hat natürlich auch noch eine Chance.
Ja, ich meine, OpenVAT macht ja auch neue Software für die ganzen Router. Und die machen das ja nicht schlecht. Du kannst ja auch der coole Hacker sagen, hier, eure Hue-Lampen sind ja ganz toll, aber eure Software ist ja mal müllig. Ich habe hier mal was eigenes gemacht.
Ey, wie geil.
Ich habe die Business-Idee. Wir machen die Philips Hue Cloud, wo du managst deine, also wir managen quasi deine Glühbirnen und spielen dir die Updates für die Leute ein. Das ist in der Cloud und alles gemanagt. Die müssen nur monatlich ihre Servicegebühr dafür bestellen.
Du hast Cloud gesagt.
Ich mache das nur, wenn ich für die auch die Lampen ein- und ausschalten darf, wie es mir passt.
Das passiert, sobald dann dein Start-up von einem größeren Energieunternehmen gekauft wird.
Oder je nach dem Preis, den du bereit bist zu zahlen, so hell ist deine Lampe dann auch im Raum. Das ist auch nett.
Auf sowas wird es bestimmt hinauslaufen. Jetzt ist natürlich, was mich schon seit längerem frage ist, diese ganze Homekit-Geschichte, die Apple aloos getreten hat.
Habe ich noch nicht einmal gestartet, aber... Stimmt, genau.
Man hat halt so ein Device nicht. Und derzeit kosten die Devices halt auch alle so zwischen...
Was sind das für ein Device denn?
Gibt es auch noch nicht so viele.
Der Mustard, Lichtschalter, Türsensor...
Da gibt es auch so einen Artikel bei dem Guba, wo er sich mal erkundigt hat. Oder meistens verlinkt er ja auch noch andere Artikel, aber er liest sich halt viel rein. Jedenfalls, was das Problem ist, warum es kaum Devices für Homekit gibt. Und ein Problem wäre wohl, dass die Developer meinen, der ist alles irgendwie die Sicherheitsanforderung von Apple. Die sind da so scheiße hoch, sie haben so viel zu tun. Oder dass es sich vom Preis irgendwie nicht mehr lohnt. Deswegen gibt es da nur so ein paar High-Profile Internet-of-Things-Geschichten. Und das ganze Billigzeug gibt es halt nicht, weil da kümmert sich halt keiner doll um Security und macht das alles doppelt und dreifach sicher, wie Apple das gerne hätte.
Genau, so ist das. Wir haben halt extrem hohe Anforderungen dafür, was wir da für Kryptographie verwenden.
Also auch richtig mit Verschlüsselung und Zeug und so. Und nicht irgendeinen AIS von vor zehn Jahren, sondern auch gleich den modernsten Scheiß.
Du kannst halt davon ausgehen, dass sie den Kram im Prinzip genauso strategisch planen, wie diese ganze iCloud-Kryptosynchel-Geschichte auch. Das heißt, das ist halt der Unterschied. Die anderen machen halt einfach, ja, hier deine Waage und unser Server und alle haben sich lieb. Und was deine Waage jetzt wirklich erzählt und wie viele Mikrofone deine Waage da eingebaut ist, weiß sie halt auch nicht.
Und ob sie dir wirklich der richtige Gewicht anzeigt?
Ja, aber gut, wenn du so weit gehst, dann ist es dir hier mit so richtig Gewichten und so.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist die erste Waage, die ich habe, die zweimal das gleiche Gewicht anzeigt, wenn man sich zweimal hintereinander drauf stellt. Immerhin haben sie dieses Engineering schon hingekascht.
Das war auch die Übersichtung, oder welche?
Es ist natürlich so, dass die ganzen Devices, die jetzt mit HomeKit-Level verkauft werden, natürlich auch alle fünf Mikrofone eingebaut haben. Und keiner merkt es. Darum geht es mir jetzt auch nicht so sehr, von so etwas überwacht zu werden. Aber ich finde es grundsätzlich bedenklich, wenn die Dinge einfach out of the box erstmal schon mal mit großen Sicherheitslücken daherkommen und so ein System, das halbwegs sicherstellt, dass die jetzt nicht gleich geohnt werden von irgendeiner wüsten Truppe. Was halt, wo ein sinnvolles VPN-Modell, und ich weiß halt nicht genau, wie es bei HomeKit jetzt konkret läuft, aber das ist halt in place. Die haben halt von vornherein sichergestellt, da ist halt nichts unverschlüsselt und alles was verschlüsselt ist, ist halt auch nur mit aktuellen Algorithmenkram und einem Minimum an Forderungen an Hardware gesichert. Ja, ist nur die Frage, wie baut man sich das aus? Wir hatten ja hier schon mal die legendäre Sendung mit Clemens und seinem ganzen Home-Matic-Kram. Ich glaube, da hat man sehr schön gesehen, was man alles Tolles machen kann mit Heim-Automatisierung. Soweit würde ich es jetzt irgendwie nicht treiben, dass mir dann automatisch auch nochmal der Gülle-Stand signalisiert wird. Aber so ein paar Sachen fände ich halt schon ganz praktisch.
Also wenn ich eine Gülle-Grube hätte, dann würde ich aber auch gerne automatisch den Stand wissen und nicht selber irgendwie mit der Lanze da drin rumkuckeln müssen.
Ich hab halt keine. Ich hab halt keine.
Aber ich kann das total gut nachverziehen, dass man genau dafür einen Wasserstand wissen will.
Was ich ja noch lieber hätte, wäre so eine Magie, ich weiß aber immer noch nicht, ob das überhaupt geht, aus einer Gasetagenheizung eine wirklich pro Raum explizit geregelte Heizung zu machen. Also ich weiß bloß nicht, ob das irgendwie überhaupt realistisch ist.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, nein. Also mit so einem Durchlauferhitzerdingens da und dann...
Wie du willst, pro Raum einfach Temperatur einstellen kann.
Ja, du brauchst pro Heizkörper einen Thermonstart, den du remote steuern kannst. Und dann muss die Heizungsanlage selber in der Lage sein, aus Vorlauftemperatur und Rücklauftemperatur zu erkennen, dass sie nochmal nachheizen muss oder so.
Jetzt machen die Anlagen doch eh oder nicht?
Ja, da habe ich jetzt auch keine genauen Kenntnisse, wie das läuft und ob es da irgendetwas gibt, was das so verhindert. Ich auch nicht. Aber im Prinzip ist es ja so, normalerweise werden die Dinger ja über ein zentrales Thermostat geregelt. Das heißt, du hast an einer einzigen Stelle in der Wohnung, da bildest du halt quasi deine Temperatur ab. Und wenn du halt jetzt individuell bestimmte Räume wärmer haben möchtest, dann musst du das quasi an dem Thermostat mehr oder weniger so relativ zu allen anderen einstellen. Also du musst ja irgendwie alle deine Thermostate manuell dann auf irgendeine komische Zahl drehen. Üblicherweise sind dann alle auf Vollanschlag oder alle sind auf drei. Weiß ich auch nicht so ganz genau, erklärt einem ja auch irgendwie keiner ausreichend. Kann man sich logisch herleiten, aber ich glaube eigentlich musst du alle aufdrehen, wenn du irgendwie eine Automat-Schriegung hast.
Ich glaube die sind so ungenau und die Serien-Streuung ist so hoch, dass die es lange aufgegeben haben, da Temperaturen draufzuschreiben. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum da eins bis fünf steht.
Das hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Nein, da steht keine Temperatur drauf. Also das ist ja kein Thermostat in dem Sinne.
Das ist ja nur ein Thermostat. Das ist es schon. Das ist ein Thermostat. Natürlich.
Das ist ein Thermostat.
Da wo die drei draufsteht.
Fünf heißt 28 Grad.
Wenn es warm genug ist, dann dreht das Ding ab. Also macht zu und dann läuft kein Wasser mehr durch.
Deswegen ist auch, das wissen auch die meisten nicht, deswegen egal.
Wenn was warm genug ist.
Genau das ist der Punkt, weswegen da nur eins bis fünf steht.
Weil es halt in der Heizungsumgebung natürlich nur funktioniert.
Weil das alles irgendwie keine genaue Wissenschaft ist, was die da machen. Es ist halt auch nur so ein mechanisches Teil. Da wird irgendwo ein Bimetall sein und über irgendeinen Umlenkmechanismus wird da halt der Pinöpel rein und rausgekippt.
Aber es gibt Thermostate, die ziemlich gut sind.
Aber wenn das so ist, ja aber dann ist es doch eigentlich ganz geil, wenn du wirklich einen Raumsensor hast, der die Temperatur misst, der 10 Meter entfernt ist.
Du kannst ja diese Knäufe abschrauben und dir da deine IoT oder wie auch immer Knäufe draufschrauben und die dann zentral steuern. Das gibt es alles.
Genau, wenn du das Ding abschraubst, dann hast du nämlich nur so eine Art Ventil mit so einem Pinöpel in der Mitte. Den kannst du irgendwie, na jetzt nicht per Hand, aber mit irgendeinem anderen Werkzeug reindrücken und dann hörst du, dass da das Wasser durchfließt.
Weil ich erinnere mich daran, dass...
Ja, wenn du es reindrückst, ist zu. Und wenn das Ding rauskommt, genau. Und dann gibt es die von minderer Qualität, die dann irgendwann nicht mehr rauskommen und dann kommt halt auch kein warmes Wasser mehr in den Heizkopf. Und dann schraubst du ab und dann ziehst du mit der Zange und dann wuppelst du in der Heer.
Das war der Heizungstechniker bei mir, weil die Heizung nicht ging so, guckst du das Ding an, dreht so zweimal, bewegt sich nichts, schraubt das Ding ab, baut einmal mit der Wurzel dagegen, macht so, plonk, fertig. Einmal wie die 40 drauf, danke, weiterfahren.
Jaja, wer kennt es nicht?
Ja, aber das ist ja so, dass so im Büro gerade, wenn es so Heizungen gibt, die nicht zentral geregelt sind und dann, sorry Mädels, aber es sind schon überwiegend Mädels, die dann die Heizung immer auf 5 drehen, sind halt temperaturempfindlicher.
Im Club sind das immer Jungs.
Ich wollt grad sagen, ich hab da auch so einen Fall.
Ich mags auch gerne warm.
Ja, aber zumindest in meinem letzten Büro war das auf jeden Fall so. Es waren natürlich auch Typen dabei. Aber ja genau, das ist gar nicht bekannt, diese wissen das 3 eigentlich schon locker leicht für...
Ja, aber was heißt denn das überhaupt?
Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt den einzelnen Heizkörper irgendwie auf 3 oder auf 5 stelle, und da ist jetzt irgendeine Temperatur mit assoziiert, der ganze Apparat läuft ja nur los, wenn das zentrale Temperaturmessgerät sagt, die Temperatur an dieser Stelle, in dieser Wohnung, ist unter dem, was jetzt eigentlich angesagt ist.
Ja, der Brenner muss natürlich heizen, und die Pumpe muss das Wasser durch diese ganze Anlage durchpumpen.
Genau, und das tut das Ding ja nur, wenn an deinem einen Messpunkt gesagt wird, jetzt bräuchte man auch mal wieder ein bisschen warmes Wasser, weil sonst könnten die Heizung halt nichts machen.
Ich verstehe das Problem, aber ich habe auch keine Lösung.
Aber dein einzelner Messpunkt, also diese Konsole für deine Heizanlage, die hat doch sowieso diese, die Heizung darf nicht einfrieren, Modus, oder nicht?
Darum geht es mir ja nicht, dass er sich nicht einfrieren kann.
Aber dieser nicht einfrieren Modus sorgt dafür, dass auf jeden Fall immer die Pumpe so ein bisschen Druck macht und dass auf jeden Fall immer ein bisschen Wärme ist. So, wenn du jetzt eine Heizung hast...
Ja, der ist immer ein bisschen wärmer, der... Na, vielleicht irgendwann mal so in kleinen Schritten, aber es ist nicht so, dass das Ding die ganze Zeit brennt.
Ja, genau, es müsste an sein.
Ja, wenn du es nicht explizit ausschaltest, die Heizung oder an dem Thermostat, das ist ein Thermostat-Heizsystem.
Wann tut sie das? Also wann geht die dicke Fette Gasboller ein?
Stell doch deinen Teil da einfach auf, sagen wir mal, 23. Das ist eigentlich viel zu viel. Aber deine Heizung hier, und hier ist das auch, wie ich sehe, ist ja ein Thermostat, da stellst du dann auf zweieinhalb.
Ich red nicht von diesem Studio mit einem Raum. Das ist doch jetzt egal. Nein, das ist genau das Problem, wenn es nicht ein Raum ist, sondern wenn du eine größere Wohnung hast.
Ich red jetzt aber erst mal von einer Heizung. Weil ich da noch nicht fertig bin.
Die Freak Show kommt langsam in Fahrt.
Dann stellst du diese eine Heizung auf drei. Das Thermostat macht dicht, wenn das warm genug ist. Und regelt runter. Und wenn es wieder kalt ist, regelt es wieder auf. Oder sorgt dafür, dass der Durchfluss so ist, dass es die Temperatur so wie bei drei, was ungefähr 20, 21 Grad sind. Jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Zimmer. Da sagst du, ist das dein Schlafzimmer, da willst du nicht so warm, da machst du nur zwei. Dann macht das Thermostat einfach früher zu. Und wenn die Heizungen alle zumachen, weil die Temperatur erreicht ist, dann kann dein Gas-Erhitzungs-Erhitzungsradar auch nichts mehr durchschieben, weil die Heizungen zugemacht haben. Deswegen kannst du in deinem Hauptregler da 23 haben, weil die Heizungen denen ist das egal, die wollen dann einfach nicht mehr.
Moment, dein Blick auf diese Problematik ist insofern falsch, als dass du immer davon ausgehst, es wird sowieso gerade unglaublich viel geheizt, und man muss nur noch rechtzeitig zumachen, und dann ist alles okay. Das Problem ist genau andersrum.
Es ist zu kalt in Raum A, in dem kein Thermostat ist.
Weil in Raum B, da ist nämlich das Thermostat, also da ist sozusagen das eigentliche Mess- und Steuergerät, und da ist alles supi.
Weil da laufen alle Heizungsrohre.
Deswegen hab ich gesagt, du sollst ein bisschen mehr einstellen, als du hast.
Moment, einstellen, ich kann ja da hinten an diesem Halskörper, den kann ich ja auf 11 drehen.
Ne, ne, wirklich Tim, jetzt hör mal Dennis zu, der sagt das schon ganz richtig.
Du sollst das auf ein bisschen höher stellen, als du überall brauchst. Das Gerät sagt eigentlich immer, es ist voll kalt hier, wir müssen heizen. Dann macht das deine Hauptheizung, aber die einzelnen Heizungen mit dem Thermostat, die sagen, jetzt ist mir Schluss mit lustig, ich mach jetzt zu per Bimetall. Und wenn da kalt genug ist, machen sie auf Wiederauf. Das heißt, dein Hauptkasten, der bei dir an der Wand klebt, der nehmt Scheiße, sagst immer viel zu viel, und deine Heizungen übernehmen individuell pro Raum. Das ist das Problem.
Du sagst, das globale Maximum gibt es dem Zentralthermostat vor.
Okay, also der Raumfühler, der will 25. Jetzt gehen wir mal so richtig hier auf 11.
Wahrscheinlich hört jetzt irgendwelche Heizungstechniker oder so zu den.
Ich akzeptiere, dass ich unter Umständen vollkommen falsch liege.
Aber bear with me, ich mach das jetzt mal so. Das heißt, wir haben da so ein Messgerät, das will gerne, dass es 25 ist. Und solange es nicht 25 ist, sagt er diesem scheiß Gasboiler, burn it baby, burn! Und der brennt so lange?
Nee, der brennt nicht so lange. Der macht sein Wasser oder sein Kreislauf heiß. Da die Heizungen aber nichts wollen und gar keine Wärme abgeben können, ist dein Heizungsding sofort heiß. Und da muss er auch nicht voll burnen, weil die Wärme ja gar nicht weggeht. Der muss auch nicht viel Energie verschwenden.
Moment, hinten gibt es aber eine Heizung, die ist auch voll an.
Ja, selber schuld, wenn du voll an hast, kriegst du voll an.
Ich will da halt wärmer als in dem anderen Raum.
Thermostat, man.
Ja, aber was ist dann? Aber dann heizt, das heißt, dann ist der Druck da, das Ding wird die ganze Zeit beliefert.
Ja, und schreit es aus, wenn es erreicht ist. Ist ja ein Thermostat.
Vielleicht solltest du mal die Heizungsrohre, die durch deinen Hauptraum gehen, alle... Mal isolieren.
Das Problem ist, ich komme einfach mit der Logik nicht hinterher. Also wenn ich jetzt einfach nur sagen möchte, dieser Raum soll jetzt wärmer sein, jetzt, ja, dann muss ich mir irgendwie voll da was überlegen, welche Heizung jetzt im Verhältnis zu welcher, wann springt die jetzt an. Ich stehe dann da vor und sage, es ist kalt, heiz du Nuss, heizt aber nicht.
Ich sag...
Wie bringe ich denn das Ding dann dazu? Dann dreh ich da voll auf, dann ist aber alles zu heiß, es ist zum Heuen.
Wait a minute, du hast, sagen wir mal, Wohnzimmer und Schlafzimmer, ja? Und jetzt sagen wir mal, ist dir im Wohnzimmer zu kalt. Du drehst dein Wohnzimmer auf und dann passiert nichts.
Ja, ein Wohnzimmer ist ja üblicherweise dann auch der Fühler, ne?
Aber wirklich, da, wo dir zu kalt ist, wenn du den volle Puller aufdrehst, dann ändert sich in den anderen Räumen auch die Temperatur. Dann funktionieren da die Thermostate nicht, dann benutzt du deine Thermostate nicht. Na, du machst das wahrscheinlich über den Hauptregler.
Und alle Heizungen sind auf.
Und dann den Heizungen nicht, weil die sind alle auf, weil der Hauptregler macht sie. Wahrscheinlich sagt die Anleitung, dass sogar bei den Heizungen alles auf 5 stellen, weil der Hauptregler macht es schon. Aber der Hauptregler macht es halt immer noch für alle oder für gar keinen. Und deswegen musst du eigentlich den Hauptregler auf, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, auf volle Pulle stellen oder auf irgendwie ein bisschen mehr als 25 Grad. Und dann pro Raum das mit dem Thermostate erledigen.
Aber wenn diese scheiß Heizungen sowieso irgendwie alle in der Lage sind, ihre eigene Temperatur festzulegen, warum habe ich denn dann überhaupt noch diesen Zentralkühler?
Das habe ich mich bei diesen Dingern auch schon immer gefragt. Ich habe so ein Ding nicht, weil ich mach das pro Heizung.
Viel lustiger ist, es gibt, also das hat Tim nicht, aber das hat meinen Modus, Dauerheizen oder aus. Also aus im Sinne von die Lampe leuchtet nicht. Wenn aber nur die Lampe nicht leuchtet, heißt es aber nicht, dass die Heizung aus ist.
Also ich habe tatsächlich auch diese Digital-Thermostate noch nie richtig verstanden, weil eigentlich das, was man machen will, was ihr jetzt ja auch beschrieben habt, das geht mit diesen Drehknäufen schon eigentlich vollkommen ausreichend.
Ich habe keinen Hauptthermostate, ich habe nur die Drehknäufe.
Was sind die Prenzlauer Berg-Probleme?
Wirklich.
Man beginnt mit diesen digitalen Thermostaten, wo man das so einstellen kann, die so eine kleine Batterie drin haben und dann den Motor drehen und so, wo man sagen kann, hier nachts machen wir aus und so. Da kenne ich jemand, der da ein bisschen mit rumgespielt hat und die tun nicht so richtig. Da kommt man von zwei Tagen Urlaub wieder, weil man über das Wochenende weg war und dann merkt man, das ganze Ding ist abgekackt und hat das ganze Wochenende mehr oder weniger mit fünf oder volle Pulle durchgeballert und die Wohnung glüht. Das ist nicht so spannend. Da wurden auch verschiedene probiert. Obwohl es eigentlich, denkt man sich, ein relativ einfaches Problem ist, tut das nicht so richtig. Aber ich würde das auch cool finden, solche Dinge mit Bluetooth oder mit irgendwie IP-Kabel. Kabel nicht. Aber eigentlich wäre das schon geil, dass man nachts mal runterregelt. Wobei das wahrscheinlich bei mir macht.
Ich habe zwei Zimmer mit Küche und Bad. Okay, vier Heizkörper. Der Default ist auf zwei gestellt, was eigentlich zu kalt ist. Und wenn ich zu Hause bin, drehe ich die Räume, wo ich bin, auf drei. Und dann ist gut.
Wenn du schläfst, drehst du runter und wenn du aufwachst, ist es kalt und bis du hochgedreht hast, bist du schon zur Arbeit.
Nee, das geht ganz schnell. Ich mache ja nicht richtig kalt. Zwei ist ja, sagen wir mal, frisch.
Also bei mir ist immer noch alle Heizkörper aus. Weil das Heizungsrohr, das geht halt von unten nach oben ins Haus.
Das freut mich auch so.
So komplett unisoliert nach oben und kommt komplett unisoliert wieder zurück. Und dann haben die an dem Abzweig noch fürs Badezimmer einmal quer so an der Wand lang. Und dann, wenn ich dann einmal im Badezimmer aufdrehe, dann ist da so viel Rohr, dass warm wird, dass es im Wohnzimmer auch warm wird. Also es ist irgendwie das...
Ja, ich hab so ein Rohr leider in der Kammer. Da ist immer schön warm. Das hätt ich mir auch an anderer Stelle gewünscht. Genau.
Hier meint einer, ich muss in den anderen Räumen den Rücklauf schließen. Ein Stück schließen. Was für ein Rücklauf?
Na, die Heizung hat ja einen Zulauf und einen Rücklauf. Aber, weiß ich auch nicht, wenn er da schließt, ist ja der Kreislauf am Arsch.
Aber...
Ja, ich seh schon grad. Da kommt jemand hier mit den Schlagwörtern ein hydraulischer Abgleich, aber dann wird's richtig kompliziert. Hab ich mich letztens auch mit beschäftigt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall zu kompliziert. Und ich finde, dass so etwas einfaches... Nein, dass so etwas Wichtiges wie eine Heizung in einer Wohnung, das muss einfach mal beherrschbare Technologie werden.
Warum die aber auch nur einen so einen Sensor haben, ich hab das nie verstanden.
Mit einer Node.js ab auf einem Raspberry Pi oder irgendwas Kleines.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich kauf auch gerne so ein Edelthermostat irgendwie mit HomeKit.
Klickt mal gleich das. Wir wollen dann mal gucken, ob das gut ist. Da gibt es sowas mit Bluetooth Smart Heizkörperthermostat.
Ja, gibt es auch hier irgendwie von...
Ja, einfach zum Austesten könnte man das ja mal machen. Das wird jetzt auch nicht so die Welt kosten.
Na ja, gibt ja da so diese...
Was cool ist, die haben auch so eine Fenster, ist offen, erkennt automatisch. Wenn die Temperatur so schlagartig abfällt, dann machen die erst mal dicht, weil sie wissen, du hast eh gerade dein Fenster offen und so.
Also...
Also wenn du hier sowas in HomeKit kompatibel kaufen willst, dann kannst du halt mal so locker...
Ja, den kenne ich ja noch gar nicht...
.70 Euro loswerden. Hier ist Elgato, die Fernseh-App.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Die machen jetzt nur noch diesen ganzen Kram.
Wo muss ich klicken?
Shut up and take my money.
Zum Rumspielen, ob der besser ist als die anderen. Ich meine, Elgato ist jetzt nicht so die......dreieinhalb Sterne.
Das sind halt die... Ja, was heißt das schon? Das sind jetzt die einzigen Sachen, die wirklich HomeKit kompatibel sind.
Das heißt, dass nicht alle 100% zufrieden sind.
Ja, aber du weißt nicht, warum sie nicht zufrieden sind.
Ja, wenn sie sagen, der Preis ist zu teuer und so, da kann man ja noch mit leben.
Warum gibt es das nur in Weiß? Zwei Sterne, ey.
Ich brauche blau.
Blaue LED ist mindestens ja sicher.
Ja, und ich muss sagen, meine Wohnung in solchen Taktungen von 50 bis 80 Euro pro Outlet auszustatten, das finde ich dann auch ein bisschen dekadent.
Du kannst ja aber mal durchrechnen, wie viel Geld du an Heizkosten sparst und wie schnell das wieder drin ist. Heizkosten ist nämlich gar nicht so ein geringer Faktor.
Das kann ich nicht durchrechnen. Das kann ich erst rausfinden, wenn ich es mir gekauft habe. Dann weiß ich, ob sich das gelohnt hat.
Na ja, guck mal, du kannst auf jeden Fall den Anteil an Heizkosten sehen und du wirst ihn auch nicht komplett wegkriegen. Also kriegst du höchstens, wenn überhaupt, auch die Hälfte gedrückt. Und an der Menge kannst du sehen, ob sie überhaupt erst mal irgendwie lohnt.
Die Hälfte, mir geht es nicht so ums Sparen, mir geht es ums Warm genug.
5 und fertig. Wenn du warm bist, machst du Fenster auf. Ich stehe aber...
Nein, das ist die Donald Trump...
Er hat gesagt, ihm geht es nicht ums Sparen.
Einfache Lösung. Einfache Lösung für einfache Probleme.
Braucht man bei diesem Elgato noch eine Basisstation?
Das ist mir auch ein bisschen so ein Rätsel. Wo kriegt man jetzt die ganze Intelligenz zusammen? Weil es ist ja schön, dass ich so einen Sensor habe, der meinen Raumklima abgreift und ich alle möglichen Dinge schalten kann. Nur, wo ist dann die eigentliche Logik so? Also, wie kann ich sagen?
Mal hier mit Siri.
Die Temperatur, die hier gemessen wird, die ist dann für dieses Ding irgendwie... Aber was weiß man nicht, vielleicht hat ja diese Heizkörper-Thermostat bisher dann eigentlich auch einen eigenen Baum.
Ja, aber ich meine, ist nicht das Problem bei denen dann auch, dass die Temperatur dann an der Heizung gemessen wird?
Ja, wahrscheinlich, da werden wir dann vielleicht auch irgendwelche Heuristiken haben. Keine Ahnung, was das jetzt wirklich rauswirft. Die eigentliche Frage ist, wenn diese Heizung selber meint, es sei zu kalt, entweder weil ich das jetzt explizit gesagt habe oder durch irgendeine Voodoo-Magic das selber rauskriegt, wie Temperatur messen zum Beispiel, kann sie dann sich einfach aufdrehen? Nein, weil wenn jetzt die Gasetagenheizung nicht liefert, dann kann die sich tausendmal aufdrehen, da kommt halt einfach kein warmes Wasser. Und ohne warmes Wasser, keine Wärme. Wie kriegt also diese Heizung, wenn sie die einzige ist, die jetzt irgendwie aufdrehen will? Alle anderen sind glücklich. Ich will nur in dem einen Raum mehr haben. Kann man die Gastherme so einstellen, dass generell, wenn Wasser angefordert wird, das Ding anspringt?
Das Ding ist auch, was einer schon im Chat richtig meint, die Heizung, also wenn du da 25 Grad einstellen würdest, das Wasser, was da durchkommt, ist ja nicht 25 Grad, das ist ja deutlich wärmer bzw. heißer.
Das ist ja okay, aber es muss ja überhaupt erst mal warm sein.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, wenn der Durchlauferhitzer halt nicht anspringt, dann ist es halt nicht warm. Aber weiß ich nicht, vielleicht, wenn man da rumsackt, kommt dann sowieso mal was Warmes, ich verstehe es halt nicht mehr, es ist einfach alles so.
Also wenn man dann so ein Haus holen will, wie ich ja, wo irgendwo im Keller für alle Mietparteien ein so ein riesen Gasbrenner da am Start ist. Das ist ja was anderes. Ja, aber es ist auch das gleiche wie bei dir, nur pro Wohnung. Da ist es halt, also könnte ich jetzt auch sagen, wenn alle Mieter im Urlaub sind und haben alle ihre Heizung ausgedreht und ich bin der Einzige, der eine Heizung anmacht, dann muss doch da trotzdem warm Wasser kommen, weil so ein leichter Durchlauf wird so eine Heizanlage immer haben.
Das Problem ist halt, wenn du in deinem Thermostat in dem einen Raum sowas wie 21, 22 Grad einstellst und in dem Raum ist 22 Grad, dann kannst du in dem anderen Raum halt die Heizung auf 5 drehen, dann passiert halt fürstwahrscheinlich nichts. Deswegen, wie Dennis schon sagte, stellst du da halt 25, 26 Grad ein, was du nie in der Wohnung haben willst, sodass sozusagen... Ja, wo sozusagen der Sensor da sagt, oh ich muss heizen, ich muss heizen, und wenn dann wirklich eine Heizung, also das lokale Thermostat sagt, ja gib mal heiß Wasser, dann kommt das halt auch. Du hast dann in einem Raum, hast du dann auf fünf gedreht.
Und los geht's. Ich gebe nicht auf, mir ist nur klar, dass ich selber einfach zu wenig jetzt, ich habe überhaupt nicht gecheckt, wie dieses Ding überhaupt funktioniert. Deswegen alle Sanitärfachleute, die uns jetzt sozusagen schon seit einer halben Stunde zuhören, Unter Schmerzen. Unter Schmerzen, sind einfach, brauchen jetzt einfach schon viel zu viel Schmerzmittel, um diese Sendung noch zu ertragen. Ich glaube, es gibt eine ganze Menge Leute, die genauso verwirrt sind wie ich.
Aber es ist doch bei jeder Sendung so.
Aber vielleicht nicht so der andere, als es sind.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall immer wieder andere halt.
Und es gibt wirklich viele Leute, und es war lange Zeit bei mir ja auch so, dass ich überhaupt nicht geschneit habe, dass diese Drehknöpfe halt mehr als nur stumpfe Ventile sind, sondern eben auch Thermostat tatsächlich.
Ja, da hießen auch schon immer Thermostat.
Ja, ich habe halt auch lange Zeit...
Selbststeuernd.
Ich habe auch. Du hast ja auch nicht von klein auf gewusst, dass da...
Doch.
Für dich gab es auch einmal diesen erhellenden Moment.
Ja, aber der ist schon sehr lange her.
Ja, du bist ja auch ein bisschen älter.
Ich... Auf jeden Fall habe ich mir jetzt mal hier dieses Elgato geklickt, weil das ist ja genau das, was ich schon immer haben wollte. Ob es gut ist, werde ich dann wahrscheinlich im nächsten Jahr wissen. Welches? Nach diesem Winter.
Welches hast du dir geklickt?
Na, das, was man an die Heizung schrauben kann. Genau das da.
Thermo.
Na dann stöpst du für meine Sünden. Das ist doch ganz gut.
Und du stöpst auch, weil du erfrierst.
Ach ja, dieses Internet of Things.
So, das Thema ist durch, glaube ich.
Das war schon durch vor zehn Minuten.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal Themen sortieren. Wir sind fast durch irgendwie. Will noch irgendjemand über GEMA reden?
Na ja, man kann es. Ist ja schon genug durch die Medien gegangen, eigentlich, dass sich YouTube und GEMA...
Ich glaube, das ist schon alles gesagt, aber noch nicht von uns.
Muss ja auch nicht sein.
Na ja, ich finde halt... Also ich hatte ja wie viele auch so immer schon so ein bisschen so Hass auf GEMA, weil irgendwie Scheiße und so, ja. Und wenn man mal eine Veranstaltung machen muss, gemacht hat irgendwo und da auch Musik im Vollprogramm lief und dann irgendwann schon mal diesen GEMA-Bogen bekommen hat, den man dann ausfüllen musste, dann hat man schon mal so dieses so, ich hab da nur ein bisschen Musik gespielt, geht mal weg. Aber auf der anderen Seite habe ich jetzt halt in letzter Zeit schon viel mit Musikern gesprochen, die so GEMA richtig geil finden, weil sie dadurch ihr Musikerleben halt finanzieren können. Insofern...
Das ist immer das Gleiche, die einen sind im Boot, die anderen sind außerhalb vom Boot. Die auf dem Boot sagen, ist doch voll geil hier, die auf dem Boot. Die außerhalb sagen, was ist das für ein Scheiß? Oder fragt man Musiker, die nicht in der GEMA sind oder da irgendwie nichts abkriegen und meinen, diese Verteilung ist nicht gerecht?
Naja, ich habe auch wirklich mit vielen kleinen Musikern schon gesprochen und es gibt Leute, die machen da echt ganz gut Geld mit.
Aber warum wurde denn so viel an der GEMA rumgezickt? Das waren ja wohl auch die User, oder?
Na, das System an sich ist natürlich immer noch verbesserungswürdig oder es ist, sagen wir mal, nicht so besonders transparent, aber es ist halt nicht nur schlecht wie so in der allgemeinen Betrachtungsweise. Vor allen Dingen halt die Leute, die ihre Justin Bieber-Videos nicht gucken konnten und deswegen sauber auf die GEMA sind. Wobei Justin Bieber sich wiederum freut, weil der kriegt jetzt nämlich dann auch wieder ein bisschen mehr Geld. Also das Problem an der GEMA in sich ist, glaube ich, der Verteilungsschlüssel, ich glaube, der ist nicht so wahnsinnig transparent.
Ja, und dann das mit dem Wahlrecht, wer vollständig ist und beissoziiert ist, Mitglied und wie es alles heißt.
Aber es gibt wie gesagt auch genug Leute, die da nicht darauf verzichten wollen. Es sind eben nicht nur die Großen, wie ich auch lange Zeit dachte, sondern halt auch viele Kleine.
Habe ich dir schon mal erzählt, dass der Typ, der die Captain Future Musik gemacht hat, Christian Bruns, der hat auch in den 70er und 60er in den ganzen Schlager geschrieben und der war mal, ist jetzt nicht mehr, glaube ich, der Vorsitzender der GEMA. Das macht natürlich total Sinn, weil er kriegt das ganze Geld, weil die ganzen Schlager natürlich richtig fett Kohle einbringen.
Mit der C3S geht es ja auch nur so langsam vorwärts. Ich weiß jetzt überhaupt nicht, was für Progress die gemacht haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wie stetig das ist. Die hatten schon so ihre Schwierigkeiten. Ob das jetzt im Wesentlichen Finanzierungsproblem ist, Mitgliederproblem ist, Softwareproblem ist, habe ich jetzt schon seit längerem nicht mehr gecheckt. Ich hoffe, dass sich da auf dem Kongress vielleicht mal wieder ein paar Leute einfinden und mal in irgendeiner Form für einen aktuellen Stand stehen. Das wäre nach wie vor sinnvoll, weil dieses ganze Anmeldungsprinzip ist halt einfach nach wie vor bekloppt. Diese ganze GEMA-Vermutung, dass irgendwie alles erst mal unter ihre Fittiche gehört, was nicht...
Ja, und dass du als Künstler halt nicht einzelne Songs bei der GEMA anmelden kannst. Du kannst dich nur irgendwie mit Mann und Maus an die GEMA verkaufen.
Genau. Also ich bin halt sehr für so ein Registrierungsmodell für bestimmte Werke, aber so funktioniert es halt nicht. Das ist das Problem.
Alles nicht so einfach.
Alles nicht so einfach. Jetzt haben sie sich halt mit YouTube geeinigt. Sehr schön. Schön für die GEMA, schön für YouTube. Keine Ahnung, wer da jetzt am Ende den längeren Hebel in der Hand hatte.
Wer von den beiden den Jackpot gezogen hat.
Na gut, die GEMA kriegt jetzt auf jeden Fall mehr Geld als vorher. Das ist schon mal klar.
Nämlich überhaupt welches.
Ja, wobei das wahrscheinlich trotzdem eher der kleinere Teil des Gesamtumsatzes ist. Es wird schon ein substanzieller Zugewinn sein. Also dadurch, dass jetzt YouTube...
Was sie normalerweise umsetzen.
Es höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich mehr. Also sie kriegen ja... Also wenn du wei... Wenn man so nachguckt, für was sozusagen Gamer-Abgaben alles fertig werden, dann sind die paar YouTube-Clicks wahrscheinlich für das... Also sie haben ja versucht, 0,375 Cent pro Abspielung zu bekommen. Oder 37 Cent? Ne, 0,3...
0,37, ja.
Also das ist nicht viel pro Klick sozusagen, für ein CD. Das wollte YouTube haben. Damals vor Gericht, oder vor einer Weile vor Gericht. Ja, Gamer wollte das von YouTube haben, natürlich. Und das hat ja... Da haben sie verloren den Rechtsstreit. Das heißt, sie haben nicht diese geforderten Betrag bekommen. Und jetzt, wenn sie sich geeinigt haben, haben sie garantiert nicht ihre ursprüngliche Forderungen gekriegt, sondern wahrscheinlich weniger. Und ihre sonstigen Abgaben, die sie so von Veranstaltungen, Radio, Fernsehen, CD und andere Medienverkäufe kriegen, die sind deutlich stärker, würde ich mal vermuten. Oder, weiß ich auch, aber...
Gut, ich meine, würde ich mal vermuten, und the power of YouTube, keine Ahnung. Also, können wir jetzt auch nur drüber raten. Die Zahlen wird es so nicht geben. Aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, sieht er dir ja so aus, dass wenn da Werbung läuft, dann kriegt er, dann geben wir da was von ab. Und wenn keine Werbung läuft, dann darf das ja trotzdem ausgespielt werden. Und dann erhält die GEMA zumindest die Abspieldaten.
Also ich hab jetzt vorhin nochmal gegoogelt, ich hab jetzt nicht so spontan also genau um diese Details schwiegen sich beide Seiten bisher aus, zumindest in den Artikeln, die ich jetzt so gesehen hab.
Ich weiß grad nicht, was meine Quelle ist, aber da bin ich mir jetzt relativ sicher. Auf jeden Fall ist es jetzt so, du kannst jetzt irgendein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk nehmen und das auf YouTube einfach veröffentlichen. Das ist ja auch mal interessant.
Wenn's GEMA angemeldet ist.
Ja, das...
Ja, wenn halt die GEMA Content ID... Ja, klar. Davon red ich nicht irgendein... Du hast recht. Also von der GEMA abgedeckte Werke kannst du halt jetzt einfach auf YouTube reinballern. Und selbst, wenn du keine Werbung dafür nimmst.
Genau, das... Und das ist ja quasi jetzt noch warum dieser Deal eigentlich so besonders ist, ist, weil es eigentlich halt keine Rechtsgrundlage gibt. So richtig, weil eigentlich die Uploader von... also Zahlungspflichtig oder Abgabepflichtig für die GEMA wären, also wenn du ein Justin Bieber Video hochlädst bei YouTube müsstest du eigentlich dafür bezahlen. Die GEMA wollte das aber von YouTube der Plattform, was natürlich auch so gesehen irgendwie schon mehr Sinn macht, aber genau, und jetzt dadurch haben sie glaube ich, oder deswegen hatten sie auch diesen Rechtsstreit verloren. Oder diese, was sie da, diese Forderungen halt nicht bekommen haben. Und dass sie sich jetzt trotzdem sozusagen geeinigt haben, das ist halt dann schon irgendwie ziemlich bemerkenswert, dass YouTube auf der einen Seite darauf zugegangen ist und die GEMA dann offensichtlich auch.
Ja, ich denke das war einfach für beide keine erträgliche Situation mehr. Also die GEMA hat auf der einen Seite den Shitstorm die ganze Zeit abbekommen. Gut, ich meine, das sind die gewohnt. Aber die dürften auch einen nicht zu unterschätzenden Druck von ihren eigenen Mitgliedern bekommen zu haben. Überhaupt mal. Ja, weil das ist ja alles sozusagen Geld, was liegen geblieben ist. Keine Ahnung, ob die jetzt noch irgendwie rückwirkend irgendwas aufmachen wollen.
Das waren 1,6 Millionen Euro, die sie von YouTube nachträglich sozusagen haben. Deswegen meine ich ja auch die...
Der neue Flow, der da eingeleitet wird, der war natürlich für sie...
Ja, aber nicht gespieltes Video ist nicht gespieltes Video. Ich glaube, das ist der eigentliche Druck, dass die Mitglieder wollten, dass die Videos gespielt werden, damit man das dann auch...
Dass man auch sichtbar ist.
Dass man sichtbar ist und dass man halt Geld dafür kriegt.
Ich glaube, die... Ja, weiß nicht, welche Bedeutung die Sichtbarkeit für die Leute hat, weil da waren ja Sony-große Fans von diesem Modell.
Und dann hattest du natürlich noch diese absurde Situation, dass irgendwelche Plattenfirmen irgendwelche Videos von ihren Künstlern zur Promotion auf YouTube hochgeladen haben und in der eigenen Seite eingebunden haben. Und dann konntest du die auf... Bei Sony Music kannstest du denn das Musikvideo nicht gucken, weil YouTube gesagt hat, konnten wir uns mit der GEMA nicht einigen. Also es muss denen ja auch so ein bisschen auf dem Pelz gebrannt haben.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, auch nochmal, die GEMA, das ist jetzt auch nicht nur Quatsch. Naja, in Details auf jeden Fall, in der Implementierung, verbesserungswürdig, aber für die lieben Musiker, die wir unter Umständen auch schätzen, nicht nur schlecht. Gibt es eigentlich sowas in anderen Ländern auch?
Die GEMA ist eigentlich schon deswegen scheiße. Weil du mit jedem Telefon, mit jedem Gerät USB-Stick und weiß nicht, wo man seinen Anteil da bezahlt. Und ja, gleichzeitig gucke ich mir bei YouTube an und muss mir aber dafür die Werbung reinziehen, womit ich sozusagen schon auch genug bezahle.
Das ist ja wirklich richtig, also man kriegt gleich Mitleidsträhnchen, dass du 1,43 Euro für deinen 699er iPhone bezahlen musst.
Das geht ja ums Prinzip, man.
Wo, wie viele Dollar bei dir direkt so in die Brust liegt.
Jetzt holen wir nicht so rum. Da kommen welche und sagen sich hier, wir kassieren einfach mal Pauschal für alles und jeden ab.
Das ist halt die GEMA-Vermutung. Ich glaube, dass die GEMA-Vermutung dann mal zu knacken ist, ist der eigentliche Hintergrund hinter der C3S. Zu sagen, wir gründen jetzt mal eine alternative Verwerterungsgesellschaft, damit die GEMA sich nicht frech überall hinstellen kann und rumheulen. Die Festplatte, die du hier aus dem Laden holst, da sind doch sowieso raubkopierte Songs drauf, was natürlich Unsinn ist.
Vor allem, wenn du jetzt eine 8-Terabyte-Platte kaufst und dir das anteilmäßig berechnen, so viel Musik gibt es gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich immer bei der GEMA.
Ja, nun.
Herzlichen Dank, dass ihr Leute Musik raubkopieren. Alles schön und gut. Aber es gibt doch trotzdem tausende Leute, die ordentlich ihre CD-Sammlung digitalisieren. Ich sehe jetzt nicht so, als wenn ich nicht zu Hause unendlich viele CDs hätte, die ich auch immer noch irgendwie digitalisieren muss. Und da sehe ich gar nicht ein, warum ich mir, wenn ich mir ein neues Telefon hole, irgendwie was ist beim Telefon? 12 Euro Anteil geht an die GEMA oder dieses Media-Tralala. Hast du nicht gesehen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Und dann rechne das mal alles zusammen. Da kannst du dir im Jahr fünf CDs kaufen.
Ich bin aber, also ich finde, ich bin auch grundsätzlich eigentlich ein Freund des Sozialismus. Und im Kernansatz ist so dieses, wir verteilen das sozusagen über alle und verteilen es dann um.
Ja, aber dann muss die Verteilung auch gerecht sein.
Genau.
Ich sag ja, an sich ist das...
Punkt ist unstrittig.
Also schon diese Trennung zwischen U-Musik und E-Musik, wo du irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wenn du ein Blatt Papier mit Noten befüllst und die irgendwo in einem Musikverlag veröffentlichst, dann kriegst du einfach von der GMA Geld, egal ob irgendjemand den Scheiß irgendwann mal zur Aufführung bringt oder nicht. Also gut, das ist jetzt etwas übertrieben, aber die E-Musiker, die E-Musiker kriegen halt einfach anteilmäßig viel mehr, wohingegen die sogenannten U-Musiker das Geld eigentlich erst reinbringen. Und dann sind da halt so Technokünstler dabei, die sehen halt überhaupt nichts für ihre Musik. Egal, ob sie es anmelden oder nicht, es lohnt sich einfach für die überhaupt nicht. Und dann sitzen da halt so Leute wie Matthias Reim, die auch niemand mehr hört und die scheffeln da Geld weg ohne Ende. Also das kann es halt nicht sein.
Ja, wie gesagt, die konkrete Implementierung ist definitiv verbesserungswürdig.
Ja, deswegen C3S.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt halt auch Leute, wo ich es gut finde, dass sie davon leben können und ihr Ding machen können.
Du, ich finde das auch gut, wenn Leute von ihrer Musik leben können, nur die Möglichkeit, also wer jetzt von der GEMA leben kann, ist halt extrem erratisch, hat man das Gefühl.
Da drehen wir uns im Kreis, da sind wir total drauf, auf dem gleichen Punkt.
Die wir jetzt, glaube ich, mehrfach Home-Gedriven haben. Einen Toast-Seite auf die andere.
Und wieder zurück, und nochmal. So, nächstes Thema, sofern vorhanden.
Bier. Thema Bier? Ganz kurz. Ich hab noch. Und zwar, ich hatte irgendwie in meinem Blog ein Bild gepostet von einem Blick durchs Refraktometer. Muss ich ein bisschen ausholen, wenn man mich nicht unterbricht. Tim lächelt schon so viel Sand. Beim Maischen von Bier wäscht man den Zucker aus dem Korn raus und die Brühe, die man da kriegt, die wird immer süßer. Und dadurch, dass die immer süßer wird, erhöht sich die Dichte davon. Und die Dichte, die kann man messen. Und aus dieser Dichtemessung folgt mehr oder weniger direkt, wie viel Zucker da drin ist. Und aus der Anzahl oder der Menge des Zuckers folgt mehr oder weniger direkt, wie viel Alkohol wird hinterher im Bier sein, wenn du es vergehrst. Zumindest dann, wenn du nach der Gehrung noch mal misst, wie viel denn von dem Kram noch drin ist, von dem Zucker. Und dafür gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, das zu messen. Das eine nennt sich Würzespindel und ist im Prinzip ein Glasröhrchen mit Gewicht unten drin.
So wie man bei Batterien den Säuregehalt misst, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man bei Batterien den Säuregehalt misst. Also du packst dieses Teil in die Flüssigkeit und je weiter es rausguckt, desto dichter ist die Flüssigkeit, desto mehr Zucker ist drin. Das ist die eine Möglichkeit. Die andere Möglichkeit nennt sich Refraktometer. So ein Teil sieht so ein bisschen aus wie irgendwie ein Fernrohr, wo das Wesentliche vergessen wurde und zur Hälfte abgesägt. Also du hast so ein Okular, wo du reinguckst und dann hast du so eine Fläche mit so einer Klappe, da kannst du so ein bisschen Flüssigkeit drauf machen, klappst die Klappe zu, hältst es gegen das Licht und man sieht das in meinem Blogpost ganz gut an dem Foto. Kannst du dann sehen, an so einer Skala ablesen, ich poste mal den, kannst du an so einer Skala ablesen, wie der jetzt der Wert ist. Einziges Problem, es gibt natürlich 1000 und 1 Skalen. Die eine heißt Bricks, die verwendet man gerne beim Wein. Dann gibt es die, wie nennt sich das, Gravity im Englischen, was im Prinzip so ein Faktor ist, 1 zu 1,0 irgendwas. Und dann gibt es, jetzt hänge ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen, beim Bierbrauen nennt man es Gratplato. Warum auch immer. Bricks und Plato sind irgendwie bis auf wenige Promille fast das gleiche. Und man will das dann irgendwie umrechnen und dann hat sich ein Hörer bei Tim gemeldet und hat mir irgendwie so ein Code für so eine App gegeben, die heißt Refracto fürs iPhone. Eine App, die heißt Refracto und die wiederum rechnet allerlei Kram in anderen Kram um. Ich habe es leider noch nicht wirklich sinnvoll verwenden können, weil es dann doch ein bisschen sehr komplex ist. Aber wer sich so fürs Bierbrauen interessiert und mal ein bisschen mit Dichte und Zuckergehalt und so weiter messen will, dem sei Refracto ans Herz gelegt.
Ich habe es noch nicht verstanden, wie man damit misst. Muss man jetzt sein iPhone da reinzumpfen?
Nein, das ist nur zum Rechnen. Also du hast dieses Refractometer. Du hast doch hier, genau, dieser Link hier. Hast du den geklickt? Genau. Ich habe da jetzt, wie das Refractometer selber aussieht, habe ich jetzt kein Bild für, aber es ist im Prinzip so ein Teil, wo du halt reinguckst. Und wenn du reinguckst, siehst du...
Du musst das beschreiben für die Hörer.
Also eine Röhre, die ist ungefähr zehn Zentimeter lang, vielleicht zwölf Zentimeter lang. Da ist auf der einen Seite ein Okular, wo man reinguckt, wie bei einem Fernrohr oder einem Mikroskop. Kannst du das vorstellen?
Ich kann mir das vorstellen.
Auf dem anderen Ende, wie gesagt, ist es so schräg abgeschnitten.
Also ich kann es mir nicht nur vorstellen, ich habe es auch schon mal gesehen.
Gut, ist schräg abgeschnitten, da ist irgendwie ein Prisma drin, wie es genau funktioniert, habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, weiß ich nicht. Und auf diesem Prisma ist noch so eine Plastikklappe. Und zwischen die Plastikklappe und dem Prisma tut man einen Tropfen oder zwei von der Würze Flüssigkeit rein, klappt die Klappe runter. Und wenn man dann durch das Okular guckt, dann sieht man etwas, wie es da auf diesem Bild zu sehen ist. Also so eine Skala, die ist jetzt...
Mit einem Schatten.
Mit so einem Schatten, genau. Die obere Hälfte ist irgendwie blau und die untere Hälfte ist weiß. Und da, wo diese beiden...
Also es muss jetzt einfach durch Lichtbrechung sozusagen. Deswegen auch Refraktometer, weil es halt mit Lichtbrechung arbeitet, wie auch mit einem Teleskop.
Aber wie gesagt, man kann mit dieser Würzespindel, die da drin schwimmt und je dichter das Zeug ist, desto weiter kommt die raus. Aus der Würze kann man es genauso messen. Interessanterweise, ich habe das erst nicht so ernst genommen, weil alle mal sagen, ja, hier bei 20 Grad messen und so weiter. Und wenn man also die heiße Würze in diesen Würzespindel-Dingens da tut und dann lässt man die stehen, dann kann man fast schon zugucken, wie die Spindel immer weiter nach oben kommt. Weil es wirklich wichtig ist, was für eine Temperatur die Flüssigkeit hat, die man dann tatsächlich mit der Würzespindel misst. Bei dem Refraktometer ist es egal, das ist ja nur ein Tropfen. Der hat dann sowieso Raumtemperatur, wenn er auf dem...
Noch nicht. Aber ich hatte schon einen sehr langen Tag.
Ja, wollte ich nur kurz erklären. Also diese Refraktor-App, die kann man sich mal angucken.
Solange der Uhr nicht falsch geht, ist der genauso lang wie bei uns.
Wir waren ein bisschen aufgestanden.
Ich? Ich frag lieber, weil ich erst mal eingeschlafen bin. Naja, ich hatte halt so drei Stunden Schlaf, und dann musste ich um neun schon mal meinen ersten Podcast aufnehmen. Und seitdem gab es auch noch andere Dinge zu tun. Nee, es war leider keine Zeit für einen Schlaf, weil da musste in der Schule leider auch noch irgendwie Personalbesprechung und Mordausfall.
Jetzt kriegst du auf den Resten des Zahnfleisches.
Es geht noch so, ich halte mich wacker. So schnell kriegt man mich hier nicht außer Kurve getragen.
Ich halte mich wacken.
Aber ich glaube, ich denke mir jetzt kein neues Thema mehr aus für unsere Liste, auf der eigentlich fast nichts mehr steht.
Und noch nie irgendwas stand. Alles ausgedacht vor Ort, improvisiert, im Pro Podcasting.
Sendung halb mal eine halbe Stunde kürzer.
Dafür war das Intro schön.
Also als Minister auf Finance kann ich berichten, in der Bitcoin-Welt tut sich bis auf den Kurs nicht so richtig was gerade.
Bis auf den Kurs, der ging ja irgendwie durch die Decke.
Ja, also erst ging er durch die Decke, weil irgendwer meinte schon vor der Wahl, wenn der Trump gewinnt, dann geht das ab. Ist auch passiert, 20, 30 Euro ging das hoch. Jetzt heute noch mal innerhalb von einer Stunde um 30 Dollar wohl. Ja, weiß nicht, was der Trump verbrochen hat, ob der damit zu tun hat. Vielleicht, vielleicht nicht.
690 Euro.
Ja, das war vor der Wahl, waren das 6,40 oder was war das?
Keine Ahnung, verfolge ich nicht so täglich.
Nicht?
Du kommst in meinem Menu-Bar, aber ich starre da jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit drauf, weil da irgendwie eh Wurst ist.
Weißwurst.
Ja, solange ich jetzt nicht aktiv damit gedacht bin, meine doch sehr überschaubaren Bitcoin-Mengen zu veräußern, werde ich da jetzt nicht unruhig deswegen. Und wenn du es irgendwie nach oben schießt, naja Gott, dann bleibt man ja eh sitzen und wartet, bis es noch höher geht. Und dann geht es irgendwann wieder runter und es bekloppt. Und dann fragt man sich, warum und überhaupt.
Der Kreislauf des Lieds.
Das ist doch immer dasselbe. Deswegen bin ich da entspannt. Aber es ist gut zu wissen, dass die paar Bits da irgendwie noch was bedeuten. Man hätte halt einfach mal ein Jahr früher einsteigen sollen, dann wäre alles anders. Aber ist halt nicht so, wieder mal eine Chance verpasst, frühzeitig in Rente zu gehen.
Die Welt braucht dich noch, Tim.
ZFS gibt es auch nicht wirklich was zu berichten, außer dass wohl das Krypto Zeugs für OS X fertig ist, aber er released halt noch nicht, weil ich glaube, die das irgendwie für alle gleichzeitig und kompatibel rausbringen wollen. Aber so grundsätzlich ist er da am Start. Wenn das kommt, kommt das für OS X auch.
Und was ist mit dem schnelleren Scrub?
Das ist ja nur so ein kleines Ding. Ich weiß nicht, wann der das released. Ich gucke da schon andauernd, kann da aber nichts sehen.
Das wäre so das nächste Feature, was mir tatsächlich einiges bringen würde.
Ja, ich würde es auch schicker finden.
Während Krypto wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass ich es mal so eben anmachen würde.
Hört man nicht ganz so lange, seht es uns nach. Wollen wir noch irgendwie letzte Wünsche sagen?
Letzte Wünsche.
Ich springe immer fröhlich um sieben aus dem Bett und freue mich auf drei Stunden Zugfahrt.
Wie drei Stunden Zugfahrt?
Von wem willst du dir denn was wünschen?
Hin und zurück?
Ich wünsche mir einen coolen Schlafplatz in Hamburg, zum Kongress.
Ja, genau. Es gibt hier exklusiv die Möglichkeit, sich hier in den original Freak Show Hacker einzutreten.
Das klingt jetzt wirklich sehr verlockend. So wie du das sagst.
Bevor wir jetzt noch viel dumme Scheiße erzählen, drücke ich hier einfach mal auf die. So, das war's. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ihr wisst ja, in zwei Wochen sind wir wahrscheinlich wieder da.
Und wir sehen uns bald.